>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> Alexander Russo: Okay.
Why don't we get started?
I have a. At the
request of Josh,
I have a brief announcement
that all the, the only open
and unlocked restrooms are
by the registration desk.
So, you shouldn't freak out
if you encounter a locked one.
I don't know if he's here.
He's probably putting
out flyers somewhere.
But I think I also
wanted to mention
that if you see him today, to
acknowledge the amazing amount
of work that he's done to put
together, not just this one,
but the previous
task force conference
and all the amazing stuff
that we are encountering here.
I don't know about
you, but as you hear,
as you can hear I definitely
conference voice, right,
which tells me that
there were lots
of good conversations
that were had.
So, I'm Alex Russo.
I teach at the Catholic
University of America.
And I'm incredibly
humbled to share this stage
with two scholars, alright,
who have defined radio studies
for the past 30 years.
I would imagine that
every person
in this room has been
influenced by their work
in one way or another.
So, to introduce them
in alphabetical order.
Susan Douglas is the Catherine
Neafie Kellogg Professor
and Arthur Thurnau Professor
of Communication studies
at the University of Michigan.
She is the author of five books,
most recently Enlightened
Sexism, The Seductive Message
that Feminisms Work
is Done 2010.
The Mommy Myth, The
Idealization of Motherhood
and How it Undermines Women,
with Meredith Michaels in 2004.
Listening In, Radio And The
American Imagination, from 1999,
which won the Hacker Prize in
2000 for the Best Popular Book
about technology and culture.
Where the Girls Are,
Growing Up Female
with the Mass Media, in 1994.
And Inventing American
Broadcasting,
1899 to 1922, in 1987.
She has written and
appeared on a wide variety
of popular publications and
radio and television programs.
She served on the board of the
George Foster Peabody Awards
from 2005 to 2011, I think.
And in 2010 was selected
as Chair of Board.
She is the 2009 recipient of
the Leonardo da Vinci Prize,
the highest honor given by
the society for the history
of technology to an individual
who has greatly contributed
to the history of technology
through research, teaching,
publications and
other activities.
Michele Hilmes is Emerita
professor in the Department
of Communication Arts at the
University of Wisconsin Madison.
Her work focuses on media
history and historiography,
particularly in the areas
of transnational media
and sound studies.
She is the author of four books.
Network Nations,
Transnational History of British
and American Broadcasting
was the most recent.
Also, Radio Voices,
American Broadcasting 1922
to 1952, in 1997.
Hollywood and Broadcasting
Radio to Cable in 1990.
And the Standard
Textbook in the History
of American Broadcasting
Only Connect, which is now
in its fourth edition
as of 2013.
She is also the editor or
coeditor of Radio's New Wave,
Global Sound in the Digital Era,
with Jason Loviglio, in 2013.
NBC, America's Network, in 2007.
The Television History Book
in 2003 with Jason Jacobs.
Connections, A Broadcast
History Reader, 2002.
And the Radio Reader, also
with Jason Loviglio, in 2001.
She was the 2013 and 14
Fulbright Research Scholar
at the University of Nottingham.
And this year, she
was the recipient
of the Distinguished Career
Award from the Society
for Cinema and Media Studies.
So, I knew, we both, all want
to hear what these
folks would like to say.
So, I think they're
going to speak
for 15 minutes or thereabouts.
And then, we'll open the
floor up for discussion.
>> Susan Douglas:
Thank you, Alex.
I too want to thank
Josh Shepard,
the extraordinary Conference
Director, for putting together
such an amazing gathering really
that brings people together
from different, yet deeply
interdependent professions,
who all have that
radio gaga spirit.
And rely so crucially
on each other.
They aren't enough conferences
that bring together
practitioners, archivists,
educators and scholars.
So, kudos to Josh for organizing
this amazing gathering, right?
[ Applause ]
Now, we are all here today
and so many of us and at 9 AM
on Saturday to affirm
that despite the overwhelming
visual bias of American history
and media history
through our textbooks,
television documentaries,
web pages and films,
we insist on the
importance of sound.
And the powerful and sometimes
dominant role of sound
in our national life,
past and present.
We are especially
interested in how sound
and listening create
communities, imagined
and otherwise, dominant
and subaltern.
How they cultivate intimacy
and individual, regional
and national identities and have
and can affirm marginalized
identities.
We seek to remind folks in
this visually overloaded age
that radio revolutionized the
perceptual habits of a nation
by bringing orality to the fore.
It forever blurred the
boundaries between the private,
domestic sphere and
public commercial life
and political life.
It made listening to
music a daily requirement
for millions of Americans.
Even after TV, radio
remained a thriving cultural
and political force.
We are also here to insist
that yes, radio matters,
radio history matters, but
also history itself matters.
With all of the interest
in media
and communication studies
today, in the uses and impact
of big data, social media,
everything in our
digital environment,
presentism is getting a
pretty big grip on our field.
And media history
is being minimized.
I think we should challenge this
and championing radio history
remains an ongoing mission.
And we are at an
interesting juncture here.
Who would've thought five years
ago that listening to stories,
mysteries, politics without
images would reemerge
as a popular and
widespread practice.
And then Serial happened in
2014 and it became a word
of mouth phenomenon
across generations.
I learned about Serial
from 20 somethings.
And now, we have
multiple true crime
and murder mystery
podcasts, political podcasts,
like Pod Save America
and Love it or Leave it,
journalistic podcasts
from the New York Times.
Even politicians are seeking
to host their own podcasts.
They are luring people into
listening and imagining again.
Will these be saved as part
of this distinctive national
moment, or will they evaporate
into the ether, like so many
previous sound broadcasts.
Everyone here knows how we
have had to be and still have
to be detectives in locating
archives, audio and print some
of them quite motley
and incoherent
and to discover what's in them.
We're learning at this gathering
how many more archives are
out there.
Some still being built
and preserved often
by indefatigable people.
Many of us in our work have
had to piece together what's
in everything from like
the Paley Center for Media
to Chicago's museum of Broadcast
Communications, to the Library
of American Broadcasting at
the University of Maryland,
to the Pacifica Radio Archives.
There is so many
more to, of course,
the Recorded Sound Research
Center here at the Library
of Congress, and many more.
Many of these, though not
all, privilege the networks
and a centralized
national history.
So, many recordings from local
stations were thrown away.
And yet, how many might still
be moldering in boxes somewhere,
probably in someone's garage.
Now, to tell our stories,
these archives were
just the beginning.
Radio and sound historians
have had
to contextualize audio archives
within the broader
printed historical record.
And this is almost
always an archive we have
to build ourselves.
How many of us have in our
offices, basements, attics,
garages, our own radio archives?
Journalistic articles, copies of
fan mail, cassettes, interviews
and the like that we
have had to put together
and we can't bear to part with.
These DIY archives help
us establish timelines,
assessed impact and
controversies
and helped us see the growing
intertextuality among sound,
image and print.
These too are part of the
radio archives infrastructure.
Should part of our preservation
task be amalgamating these
archives that we
each have built?
Probably if we did, it
would fill the entire floor
of this building.
Part of our preservation
task, also have to do
with preserving the oral
histories we collected.
The audio interviews we've done.
I have at least two huge file
drawers filled with my archive
for Listening In,
merely 20 years old now
and I cannot bear
to throw it away.
Who would take them?
Where would they go?
[Inaudible].
[Laughter].
So, where do, where does radio
studies seem to be going?
First, of course,
is the decentering
of the National Network story
and the golden age of radio.
And the exhuming and preserving
of local and regional histories.
This conference, recent research
and the archives still
emerging document the crucial
and massively underappreciated
role that radio, especially,
but not solely community and
listener supported radio,
played in addressing and giving
voice to marginalized groups,
including the LGBTQ community
as early as the 1970's,
indigenous first nations
communities, Chicano and Latinos
and African Americans.
More histories can and need to
be written about the connections
between such stations, this
kind of radio listening,
community building and
political activism.
Also, we have to remember
that in 1971 the FCC issued
its primer on ascertainment
of community problems
by broadcast applicants,
what a euphonious title, which
gave detailed instructions
on how to determine
community needs.
Stations had to develop
an ascertainment procedure
that would document
the demographics
of the stations market, identify
what were called significant
community groups and
hold meetings with them
to discuss community needs
and propose programming
that would meet those needs.
These had to be filed
with license renewals.
So, what were commercial
stations doing
in the 1970's before Reagan's
FCC rescinded these rules
that might also have covered and
given voice to underrepresented
and marginalized groups?
When we find them and we can
use these available clips
to teach our students about
radios unsung role here.
And this is an important
way to link our colleges
and universities
commitments to diversity,
to teaching about previously
ignored histories that matter.
And I'm stealing a line that
Kathy Battles gave me yesterday.
These broadcasts with their
community building functions
constitute, and this
is a quote from Kathy,
the prehistory of social media.
And she's totally right.
That's maybe how we should
teach some of these materials.
And let our colleagues
and ethnic studies,
sexuality studies
and other fields know
that they're out there.
Another possible
future is to continue
to study listening itself
from radios multiple modes
of address, the phenomenology
of listening,
to how we engage cognitively and
emotionally with what we hear.
How do we, ourselves
as researchers,
engage with audio archives?
We've come a long way
in the past 30 years
in developing analytical
frameworks
to conceptualize the role
and impact of radio and sound
on American culture, politics,
the economy and on racial,
class, ethnic and
gender identities.
But what would we
say our methods are?
Especially once we're
in the audio archives
and we're listening.
For those of us who are, who
are humanities based scholars,
we don't have a tradition like
our social science colleagues,
in laying out in often
painstaking detail what our
methods are.
Yet, many of us have tried to
construct a kind of semiotics
of sound as part of our methods,
which don't really exist,
aren't terribly codified
and maybe can't be.
Now, of course, we focused on
the content of radio broadcast,
its distinctive language,
its mode of description
on the development and
use of sound effects,
on music as a punctuating force,
on radio voices and as gendered
and raced and the like.
In my own work, I sought
to develop an archeology
of listening, proposing
what types
of listening may have
emerged or evolved over time.
And how mode of address, tone
of voice, vocal acrobatics,
linguistic slapstick and the
like may have shaped
broadcasting practices
and listening repertoires.
Now, whether what I proposed
holds up, I don't know.
but sharing with each other how
we listen, what we listen for,
what we believe different
sounds signify
and what we think their
dominant, oppositional
and negotiated readings
might be,
might help elaborate our
collective understandings
of the semiotics of sound,
especially of radio
broadcasting.
Another direction
for radio studies is
of course analyzing the
phenomenon of the podcast.
You can barely keep
up with them.
And many are followed
by young people.
What other different
modes of address?
They're journalistic practices.
They're presentation of
different identities.
Now, I have one you might
find odd observation
that distinguishes some of them
absolutely from broadcast radio.
One thing about the few
podcasts I listen to, Love it
or Leave it, Pod Save America,
occasionally My Favorite Murder.
Do you guys know
My Favorite Murder?
Okay, yeah, yeah, okay.
Is the way they create intimacy
and bond with their audience,
in part by relying quite
frequently on the F word,
particularly as an adjective.
These podcasts rely on a
combination of humor, political
and social commentary and
outrage and are geared primarily
to those in their 20's
and 30's, for whom,
at least in my experience, the
F word is one of the more common
and emphatic adjectives,
regardless of gender.
And it is used to convey
anger, disgust, outrage,
but also with an edge of
irreverence and humor,
as in that is fucking crazy.
It almost always has
nothing to do with sex
and is rather an exclamatory
filler affirming defiance.
This would be impossible
on broadcast radio.
And its frequent use works to
create an in club of listeners
who don't care about
stodgy old forms of decorum,
censorship or [inaudible].
These broadcasts, these podcasts
are often staged before a live
audience, also to create
a sense of community.
So, radio and listening
are not dead.
And podcasts are bringing
this new form of engagement
to a younger generation.
How they create intimacy is
just one of many questions.
But their affordances
are a bit different.
We listen when we want
with others or alone.
They are not constrained
by broadcast regulation.
Knowledge of them spreads
primarily by word of mouth,
which is always such
a mysterious process.
How do we grasp this
new phenomenon
and its generational address?
How are gender and race
performed on these podcasts?
And have they more closely
connected the voices
of young women to politics,
even though Love it or Leave it
and Pod Save America
are hosted by white men.
And as we think about the
future of radio studies,
one framework can be our
wireless imagination.
How the imaginary about radio?
Who the audience is?
What radio was and
is meant to do?
How it connects with politics
and a longing still
for community?
As a through line
from wirelesses earliest
days up to the present.
Does radio studies include
services like Spotify,
Apple Radio, iTunes and Pandora?
And how music listening
has changed again
with these services,
with no DJ to hail us,
no ads if you pay enough,
songs and playlists selected
for you not by a DJ,
but by algorithms.
The AIing of taste.
I think this should be
part of radio studies too.
Finally, what is so striking
about this conference is
the enormous energy about
and commitment to embracing
and sustaining this
wireless imagination,
its history and its future.
And I look forward to hearing
where you think radio
studies is going.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Michele Hilmes:
I'll go over there.
I have a few slides, not many.
Now, woops, I got to.
Can we bring my PowerPoint?
And here it comes.
Yeah, there.
Okay, good, good.
So, we. I think we're going
to have a little discussion
between ourselves,
because I am going
to start just a little
bit by talking about.
This is one thing that
Alex had actually suggested
as the convener of this session,
are, you know, our backgrounds,
which are similar,
but different.
And sort of what we
bring, what, you know,
originally many years
ago perhaps we brought,
Susan and I brought to the field
of radio studies and then how
that might affect,
you know, our vision,
which I think are very
similar, to where we are
and where we might go.
But, I think the other
kind of task of this,
this session this morning was
to say okay, you know, we,
as Susan has just really
admirably described, we,
this field has grown
so enormously.
It's so great to see.
I mean, I can't even imagine a
group like this 20 years ago.
I mean, it just didn't exist.
I mean look at all the people
in this room that have done
such fantastic work in radio and
sound studies and all the kinds
of different things
that Susan was saying
that our field has
expanded into.
I'm just going to
give a brief plus.
I'm pushing for that
term sound work.
Some of you have heard
me expound on this.
I've written on it.
You know, it's just like I know.
You know, how do you
get a new term induced,
or introduced into
the vocabulary?
But I think, I think we
need a term sound work
that would encompass radio
and I'm not erasing radio,
but that would factor in all
these other new forms and also,
you know, things that we don't
have a good way of talking
about now, like music
presentation.
You know, music is one thing,
but how it's been presented
on the radio is a whole separate
kind of form in and of itself.
So, I'm not going to go
down that rabbit hole.
Although, if you want to ask
me about it, I will talk.
But anyway, I couldn't
resist giving a plug
to this group in particular.
So, when I thought about
what to say at the beginning
at the second day
of this conference,
in terms of going forward
in radio, I thought again,
you know, my background
is in the humanities.
I came to the study
of radio through first
of all cinema studies at NYU
way back in the late 70's.
But before that, I was a
comparative literature major
at Indiana University,
working with Jim Naramore
and a few other people
that I think would be
known in this group.
And just at that
moment when I was there,
they had started a
film studies track
in comparative literature
and I took that.
And so, I was really coming from
this background and thinking
about texts and thinking
about modes of expression
and narrative structures
and things like that.
And, although, I
think, you know,
the other great thing is I think
some of you have heard me say,
is when cultural studies met
with media studies in the 80's.
And we began to think much more
deeply about issues of power
and identity and the
cultural significance,
the cultural activity
of media in our society,
you know that that
is a formative moment
that has shaped, you know,
so much of the work that's
been done in this room.
But also, I like to think about
radio studies or sound work
as still centrally
studying texts.
I don't want to turn
lose of the idea
that radio has produced
these wonderful texts,
these formal constructed
expressions of meanings
of various kinds that need to
be analyzed in much the same way
that we've, you know, we analyze
film, we analyze literature.
And I think as Susan
also suggested,
we're still in the
formative days of that.
So, I want to go through.
I could, of course, you know,
in fact, now that I've retired,
I really, what I really love
doing and I do it all the time
through kind of interpersonal
networks is recommending all the
great work on radio that's come
out of the people in this room
and others since this
field has gotten started,
because there are so
many people out there
in other fields besides ours
that are looking to connect
with sound work now
[inaudible] exactly
of these new forms
that are out there.
People in the humanities,
people in the social sciences.
I get probably one
query a week by email
from somebody who's saying,
you know, I'm really interested
in the intersection
of theater and radio
and surely someone has
written about this.
You know, where's,
where's the book out there.
And I say, you know what,
there's some in the 40's.
You know, and there's some
really great work that touches
on that now, but it's a
literature waiting to built.
So, what I thought I would
like to do today is to kind
of give a shout out to some of
the ways that I think that we
as radio studies scholars
might work towards reaching
out to other fields
and I'm focusing
on the humanities myself,
but I think it's just as true
for the social sciences and for
other kinds of academic fields
to get the word out there of
this work that we're doing
and also of these
incredible archival sources
that we are discovering
that need to be heard.
And on a, as kind
of a side note,
although this is
something I hope we can talk
about in the discussion
that follows,
how we can just communicate
amongst ourselves better too
about these.
You know, when we
come together, I hear,
I've heard about 15
archival collections at least
in the last day and a
half, you know, that were,
that I just can't wait
to explore further.
But I wouldn't have known
about them unless I had
come here to hear people.
So how can we, you know,
just extend our reach?
So, I'm going to, I just
want to talk about some work
that I think, that has
come out of other fields
that is really interesting and
suggestive of how our research
and our archival
efforts can be of use
to scholars coming
from other areas.
And I apologize.
I would be.
I could talk about the
work that's just come
out of this room.
But I'm purposely going
outside for the most part to,
to focus on the work by
people who are not here today,
but would probably
really benefit from being.
Now, let me see.
There we go.
So, for instance, I want to give
the example of a student PhD
at Wisconsin from the English
Department at Wisconsin,
whose name is Lisa Hollenbach,
who just got her doctorate
about two years ago.
And I wanted to put up.
Let me just tell
you what the, her,
the title of her dissertation
was Alternative Networks,
Recording and Broadcasting
American Poetry after 1945.
I think the dissertation might
be embargo because I can't,
I couldn't put my
hands on a copy.
But I'm sure it's
going to come out soon.
But she ah a really interesting
article if you'd like to read it
that came out in American
Literature, Sono-Montage,
Langston Hughes and
Tony Schwartz Listen
to Postwar New York.
So, this is a literature student
taking the field of poetry
and the poetry of Langston
Hughes in particular,
putting it together with the
sonic work of Tony Schwartz
and his portraits of New
York and looking at the kinds
of evocative sounds, the kinds
of structures of storytelling
that exist in those two
very different areas.
And, you know, making
this wonderful connection
between the culture of the
1940's and it's, you know,
essential engagement with
radio and with recording.
Another example and this one
might seem a little abstruse,
but let me tell you it's
a really interesting book.
It's from a British scholar
called Amanda Wrigley.
And it's Greece on the Air,
Engagements with Ancient Greece
on BBC radio and this is from
the 20's through the 60's.
And it's not only
about Greek drama.
Yes they put on, you know,
the BBC did all kinds
of Greek drama on air.
But also representations
of Greek culture,
the way that Greek literature
of various kinds kind of entered
into not only the
programs, but the basic ideas
of what drama was and how
poetry engaged with radio.
Again, you know, a humanity
scholar who came to radio
and really had learn
it from scratch
and is doing this kind
of interesting work.
I think there's lots
of colleagues
out in literature
departments and other kinds
of arts departments who would be
really, who need to hear from us
and need to know what
we've been doing.
Here's another example,
slightly different.
Simon Potter.
This is again, a Brit.
He's at the University
of Bristol.
And he got into from
a background
in modern history this book
Broadcasting Empire, the BBC
and the British World.
Again, he was a person who
said, you know, I'm interested
in empire and the
structures of empire
and how the British Empire
was built and established.
Radio was imperative.
How do I find out
more about radio?
Where are the resources?
And he went on from there to
and just put together a group
that he's running now.
It's a Leverhulme trust
supported research network,
connecting the wireless world,
writing global radio history
with a consortium
of scholars from,
well a lot of different
countries.
So again, you know, this
kind of effort to reach out
and to broaden the
relevance of our field
and to support the
humanities at a time
when humanities is
being questioned
and in some cases undermined
by pointing to this vital field
of endeavor that
we're all engaged in,
I think is a really
important task for us.
So, and then secondly,
so the second.
So, this one thing reaching
outwards to other fields
and demonstrating the
relevance of our research.
The other thing, again touched
on before by Susan and by,
yeah I've been sort of harping
on this for a little while.
Maybe some of you have read
my Lost Critical History
of Radio essay, where I'm
talking about where is
that critical vocabulary
that has been built
up in the other arts?
How do we talk about
radio texts as narratives,
in terms of the expressive
elements that are available
to us, in terms of their
relationship to other kinds
of genres and modes
of expression?
And I hope that most of
you are familiar by now
and if you aren't, I hope
you will become familiar
with the really great work
that Siobhan Mccue is doing
out of the University of Monash
Australia with Radio Doc Review.
And that's small and I
don't know if that title.
Well, maybe you can see it.
Radio Doc Review.
I've just put up the
contents of the latest issue.
And so for the last,
I think, two years.
This is an online journal only.
She's working with creators of
podcasts, of radio programs,
of different kinds
of audio work.
And having them review other
peoples work and also reaching
out to scholars to do reviews.
You know, serious in
depth critical reviews.
I don't know if Jason
is here today.
But he has a review, as
you might see up there,
Jason Loviglio, of Criminal.
Isn't that a podcast that
some of you might know?
And I also have to point
out that yes, Neil Verma,
I think, Neil, you may be the.
I had to make an
exception on Neil's behalf.
He's probably the only person
in the audience whose
work I'm mentioning,
even though you all
deserve mention,
because he has a really
fascinating two part essay here.
The Arts of Amnesia, the
Case for Audio Drama,
where he really does this job
that I've just been waiting
for somebody to do, to
connect the kind of aesthetics
and central questions
and modes of radio
from the earlier period
and podcasting today.
And it's a really
fascinating essay.
But, you know, Neil, I'm really
becoming worried about you
because you listen more.
You've listened to more radio
drama, as far as I can tell,
just quantifiably, than
any other person I know.
And like when do you do this?
You know? I know you have a, you
work, you have a demanding job.
You have a family.
You know, I beginning to
think do you not sleep.
You know. Okay, good,
I'm glad to know that.
But, yeah.
What is that?
[Inaudible].
Oh, so he's just
constantly getting
through the fillings
in his teeth.
Oh, you know that is brilliant.
I've got to figure
out how to do this.
That's all I can say.
But it's really interesting
critical work.
And I think Siobhan,
like on a shoestring
and getting very little
credit from her university
because she has been involved
herself as a radio producer has.
It's a, I think, I
don't know how many.
Well, it probably
tells me doesn't it,
what issue we're up to.
Volume three, issue one.
I think it's four a year.
It's a really incredible
resource.
I want then also say that
I've been really encouraged
to see other things, other
kinds of venues where people
who are doing kind of the, you
know, humanistic assessment of
and building up of a critical
vocabulary and repertoire.
And I hate to mention the
word cannon because I think
that it has such a negative,
you know, implication.
But to talk about like what
is really great radio work
that we should be remembering?
And I think all of us have
our personal, you know,
little cannon that
we have in our head.
But its things like awards and
prizes and recognition that sort
of build this up
more publically.
And, of course, the Peabody has
been doing that for a long time.
And I've been on the, one of the
Peabody prescreening committees
for a couple of years,
a couple of years ago,
along with some people
in this audience.
And they're great.
But they don't.
You know, it's a policy of
the Peabody's not to talk
about the criteria, the
methods or anything.
Never to reveal.
Never to actually set
criteria except excellence.
Okay. You know, but,
you know, could we talk
about it a little more?
And I think that this is an
award called the Sarah's,
which comes from Sarah
Lawrence College.
And maybe some of you know about
it, where every year they have,
they give out a couple of
radio awards, bring people in.
And I have to, and they put
out, they also have a website
on which they publish
articles about the radio dramas
and other documentaries
that they give awards to.
And I want to point you
in particular the one I
found really fascinating,
because she was doing exactly
what I was saying somebody
needed to do in the, in
the lost art of radio.
Sorry. I forgot the title
of my own article now,
but could you please
fill that in.
The Lost Critical
History of Radio.
And it's called Towards
the Poetics of Audio,
the Importance of Criticism.
And she's a producer,
not a scholar
and it's a really
interesting article to read.
I'd recommend it.
and then, finally, and I'm
probably wrapping up fast,
which I think is good, because
one thing that we did want
to do here was, you know,
get more dialogue going
amongst ourselves this morning
since we have a little
time to do it.
How many of you know
about Radio Atlas?
You know, you know the old saw,
there are no subtitles
in radio, right?
Which makes it hard for us to
listen out, to use a phrase
from Kate Lacey, a British radio
scholar, because the radio is
in different languages.
And unless we are really
familiar with the languages
that it's in, it's very hard
to listen to French radio,
to German radio,
to Assyrian radio.
We just cannot do that.
This is a effort of love
run by Eleanor McDowell.
And she's a producer
of radio too,
working with Falling Tree
Productions, Alan Hall,
a really well known group of
producers that subtitles radio.
You go online and there's
wonderful radio dramas
from around the world and
you can listen to them
in the original with
subtitles running
so that you have a translation
of what is being said.
And it's, you know, she's
doing it on a shoestring.
She actually emailed me one
time and said, I don't know
if you know who I am, but I have
this Radio Atlas site, you know,
you know you might
find it interesting.
And I said, oh I've
written about it.
She's a. So, it's an
effort to kind of reach
across national boundaries
and linguistic difference
and I think a really
promising thing for sound work.
And I'm using the term radio,
but I'll go back to sound work.
And it's future and its impact
in the larger intellectual
and cultural universe.
So, thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Alexander Russo: Thank
you both, Michele and Susan.
I think there's former.
We had a brief conversation and
I think yesterday about this.
And what I think really came
out of it were both the ways
in which I think we
share or both of these,
or both of these talk share,
right, both are sort of focused
on the simultaneously, alright,
looking to the importance
of the past and the history,
but also recognizing the
tremendous moment we are
in right now, right?
The renaissance of sound
and its importance and sort
of centrality within
our larger culture.
So, that's one sort of way
of sort of both looking back
and looking forward, but
also the, the insistence
on both [inaudible] specificity,
alright, and certain ways
of talking about audio
and sound as sound, right?
But also the inherently
multidisciplinary way
in which we need to look
at various kind of context
as radio cuts across
aesthetics and technology
and identify and economics.
And so, I think this sort of
provides a really important way
for us to begin to, you know,
have our, have this conversation
about where we will go
forward in radio studies.
And so, with that, I want
just to open it for questions
that you guys had or if
you guys wanted to respond
to one another, if that would.
We could also do that.
>> Michele Hilmes:
Here's someone.
I'm not sure he's qualified
to ask a question here
[laughter] in this room.
Bill Siemering.
>> Bill Siemering: I
don't want to add to the.
I mean there's so many
things that [inaudible].
But I've been working
in radio and development
in developing countries and
there are studies on impact.
This is where you still have
radio as a primary source
for over 80 percent
of the people.
And it's transformative.
We know the story of
[inaudible] historically.
But now, I've done case
studies of a radio station there
that has sponsored 40 live
debates in the last year.
>> Michele Hilmes: Wow.
>> Bill Siemering: And there
are radio listening [inaudible]
and the engagement
of the community
with the radio stations
is quite amazing.
I just want to add one little
footnote from yesterday.
I had mentioned this is a
radio, you know [inaudible].
>> Michele Hilmes: Dammit.
[ Inaudible ]
How true.
I don't know, could
people hear that at all?
Okay. So, just to say,
just to summarize.
First of all, it was, oh jeez
I'm going to work backwards
and then you'll help me.
Some things like Chapter a Day,
really a precursor to audio,
which was on, what
starting from the 20's?
Wasn't it?
And also University of the
Air, yes like Ted Talks.
So, kind of interesting
parallels in it and some
that we could, that we
could draw on today.
And you also said you just
wanted to say that it was,
this is radio dammit,
as you said yesterday,
that was really the
precursor to Terry Gross's,
or was Terry Gross's program.
And I'm sorry, you
were making a point
about developmental radio
too about how many debates?
[Inaudible].
In Rwanda.
>> Bill Siemering: In Rwanda
a station has 40 live debates.
>> Michele Hilmes:
40 live debate.
Yeah, transformative.
>> Donna Halper: Donna
Halper, Lesley University.
>> Michele Hilmes: Oh Donna.
>> Donna Halper: If you guys
have already addressed this.
My apologies if you guys
But could we say a couple of
words about college radio?
And the reason I
wanted to say something
about that is I see an
incredible negativity
that really scares me at
a lot of college campuses.
It used to be that those
of us who are broadcasters,
whether we're doing podcasts
today or streaming audio
or blah, blah, blah, we all
got our start in college radio.
And in university
after university,
I'm seeing people say, well
oh kids today they don't care
about radio, so we're
getting rid of our station.
We're selling off our assets
and that makes me
incredibly nervous,
because A -- it's our history.
But B -- radio has
always done a horrible job
of telling our story, okay.
And I say that.
I'm not telling you anything
you don't already know.
I'm, you know, just one of, many
media historians are sitting
in this room and
I am one of them.
But it really breaks my
heart to see years and years
of history just dismissed
like oh kids today don't
care about that anymore.
And when I look at my students
and I ask them whether
they use radio,
they generally say they do not.
And when I was a kid growing up,
I couldn't imagine anything
better than being a DJ,
than being on the air.
And I said on another, someone's
podcast last year, I said,
you know, kids today
don't have radio dreams.
So, to some degree I
feel like we are trying
to preserve something.
But we're also trying
to sell something.
Does that make any sense?
Not sell it like money
wise, but sell our story.
Let people know that we still
matter, that we're still here
and we're still important.
>> Michele Hilmes: Do you
guys want to respond to that?
>> Susan Douglas: Well, I don't
have too much to say about that.
You know, when I went to
graduate school at Brown,
there was a student run
station there that was also,
was a commercial station.
And had a lot of
students involved in it,
including myself,
enormous impact.
I think it's still going strong.
But it was primarily, you know,
they didn't, they did news
and of course a lot of music.
I don't know what they're
doing now at Michigan.
We don't have, you know,
we don't have an official
college run radio station
in the same way.
We have an NPR station.
So, you might want to
talk about this a bit.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Alexander Russo:
Yeah they did.
>> Susan Douglas: Did they?
>> Alexander Russo: Yeah.
>> Donna Halper: And
their assets were sold
to a Christian broadcast.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Susan Douglas: Oh that's sad.
I mean they were, it
was a great station.
Yeah, yeah.
>> Alexander Russo: Yeah
and actually Nate Demayo
[assumed spelling],
who also has a wonderful
historical podcast,
wrote a great, amazing
[inaudible] for WBRU
that was just was published
like a couple weeks ago.
But. And, and like on one
hand, yes Donna I agree
that maybe students
don't have radio dreams.
But I do think they have
sound dreams, right?
And one of the things
that, that, and, you know,
we can debate the essential
importance of, I don't know,
liveness within radio, right?
Because that is something
that's, that is lost
with podcasting, right?
But the, you know, the fact
BRU is able to continue online,
right, also sort of suggests
the resilience, right,
of the ways in which people are
embracing and using sound to,
you know, say something
about their lives,
form these different
kind of communities
and express themselves
in various ways.
So. [Inaudible].
>> Just I want to put
in a plug for a website
and podcast radio survivor.
I know Jennifer Waits is here.
I don't know if other folks are.
But, about a year ago they
did an episode, maybe two,
excuse me, conference
voice, no how colleges
and universities can
save their stations
and how they can start making
the case before the commercial
broadcaster or the Christian
broadcaster comes in and wants
to take over, you know,
buy their facilities.
Because it's easy for university
presidents to see this as a pot
of money, you know, a gold
mine that they're sitting on.
And so, how to already
begin now making the case
and like annual reports and
different things that colleges
and universities can do
proactively and preemptively
to save whatever college
stations might they still have.
So, talk to Jennifer Waits or
just look up Radio Survivor.
And it's about a year ago.
Maybe Jennifer knows more.
But I just wanted to
throw that in there.
It is something that we as,
those of us on college
campuses can be doing right now
to save radio.
>> Michele Hilmes: And
I would just add, as,
just to take Alex's phrase,
they're have sound
work dreams, students.
I mean, can we tie, you
know, the popularity of sound
in general to the
radio stations?
Aha that's a really
good strategy.
>> Alexander Russo: Behind Bill.
Maybe it would help for the mic.
>> I'd like to respond
to that as well.
The work I'm doing is at
Indiana State University.
The person I am researching
built WISU.
It's been in business
for over 50 years.
That station started
going downhill,
same problem, but in the 90's.
There is a young man who took a
program management position four
years ago at that station.
His name is Rich Green.
And he is rebuilding
that radio program.
And his students are
excited about it.
So, there is hope.
It's not all doom and gloom.
>> Alexander Russo: I don't
know, Jess, you have the mic.
So that probably gives you
a certain amount of power.
>> Bala Baptiste: Okay.
Thank you.
Bala Baptiste, Miles College.
Will you comment on ideas
that terrestrial radio
is on the decline?
And on the rise is
streaming, satellite
and other digital platforms.
>> Michele Hilmes: I would just
say at least we haven't shut
down all of our FM
stations here,
like they did, was it in Norway?
Just this last.
But, you're right.
You know, not to
minimize it, I think.
Because that brought
out all these issues
of well what does terrestrial
broadcasting give us
that streaming can't possible?
And, of course, it
was immediately,
I mean you can see
the significance
for emergency broadcasting
and also for, you know,
all it would take is
for a few servers to go
out for the streaming
services to get interrupted
and I'm sure we've
all experienced this.
And also that for certain kinds
of applications, like radio
and automobiles, I mean it's,
it's vital to have
broadcast radio.
You know, I keep thinking
and I'm no expert on this,
so I'm just sort of wishfully
hoping that, you know,
there are ways to
tie those together.
So, that they remain vital.
But, I don't know, I mean
do you think we're in danger
of terrestrial radio
being phased
out here in the United States?
>> I think that's an aspect of
the way radio is overlooked.
>> Michele Hilmes:
Here comes the mic.
Here comes the man with the mic.
>> We'd have to look
up the details.
Oh you have to turn it on?
[ Laughter ]
You know, I can't quote the
statistics accurately right off
the top of my head.
But I think the idea
that terrestrial radio is
in decline is part of the way
radio gets overlooked as the,
some of the points Susan
Douglas was starting out with.
90 some percent of
Americans listen
to radio at least once a week.
And most of them listen
to it every morning.
And. but it's built into,
into our daily routine.
We overlook it.
You know, we don't,
we experience it
as routine, not as special.
>> Susan Douglas: You know,
I think part of this is
and I'm revealing
my own generational
identification here.
But, but with so much
emphasis on Millennials.
What are they doing?
How are they driving?
All kinds of marketing.
That can drive also this
overlooking of radio.
And, you know, and
I mentioned podcasts
because that's what a lot
of them are listening to.
And one of the reasons
that they, that they,
that some of them have, at least
in their late teenage and sort
of early to mid 20
years abandoned radio is
because commercial radio
ruined itself, right?
I mean Clear Channel ruined
it, ruined itself, you know.
[Applause].
>> It destroyed itself.
>> Susan Douglas: It destroyed
itself, you know, with these.
[Inaudible].
Yeah. I mean the music
formats are a nightmare.
And so, we, we actually have
in Ann Arbor, 107.1, which is,
I think it's a Serious station.
No not. No, what's
the other one,
not Clear Channel [Inaudible].
>> Alexander Russo: Cumulus?
>> Susan Douglas: It might
be a Cumulus station, yeah.
And so, we have this DJ, who's
like the morning DJ and a lot
of stuff comes down from
corporate, you know,
that he's sort of stuck with.
But, on Sunday he has his show.
And he's an actual DJ.
And he knows everything
about producers.
And they fired him a
couple of years ago.
They fired him.
But the community went crazy.
People were outraged.
And one of the main
advertisers, a bank in town,
said they were going to yank all
of their advertising unless they
put that guy back on the air.
And he is an example of
how radio can still thrive
and really speak to an audience.
That is in utter
counter distinction
to the clear channeling
of radio.
No wonder young people don't
listen to the radio, you know.
But, I'm finding
that some of them,
I have quite a few
20 something friends,
in part because of my daughter.
They, they get out of college
and they're driving to work
or they're, they start
listening to NPR.
>> Michele Hilmes: That's true.
>> Susan Douglas: You
know, and so, that's.
And they're listening
to podcasts
because they're getting
something they think is genuine.
They're not getting commercials
and they're not getting
Clear Channel.
>> Jennifer Waits:
Okay, it was on.
Jennifer Waits from
Radio Survivor.
I'm, I haven't heard
anybody talk
about low power FM
at the conference.
And for me, having
visited a bunch
of brand new low
power FM stations,
I feel like this is an
unprecedented point in,
in radio history, in our
lifetime where we're getting
to see so many brand new radio
stations at the same time.
So, I see a lot of energy
in terrestrial radio
around low power FM's.
And maybe because they're
hyper local, it hasn't become
as much of a national story.
And maybe because
they're so new,
it hasn't become an
academic story yet.
But within the community,
radio community,
this is a huge incredible
period of time
and I'm seeing young people
engaged with these new stations.
And it's just a really
interesting energy
and I would also agree
that I think young
people often don't realize
that they're actually listening
to radio when they're in the car
and there's a radio on.
And it's like this ambient.
So people say, no I
never listen to radio,
but they probably are actually
listening to radio every day.
So.
>> Susan Douglas: You know, I
do wonder, we're at, you know,
with the Twittering of
America and the often, the,
how negative a space Twitter
can be and has become.
And also some other aspects
of social media have
become nasty places.
Whether things like lower
power FM are going to be kind
of the antidote or
the anti Twitter move
to community building, because
you do have some community
building on Twitter.
But you also have community
annihilation on Twitter too.
So, I'd actually love to
hear more about what you've,
where around the country
you've found all of this.
>> Michele Hilmes:
Just to piggyback
on that really briefly, I mean
I'm sure you know this Jennifer,
but, you know, it's
editing the journal,
we just did a special
issue on community media.
And it is amazing.
I mean, Bill knows this.
In Africa community radio is,
you know, the, in South America,
in Europe, I mean there's so
much enthusiasm and excitement
and new stations
coming on all the time.
And I just, you know.
We got very few submissions
to that issue
from people in the
United States.
And now, maybe the
excitement level is, we need,
you know, it's not quite there.
But I wish it could be.
>> Just quickly, the University
of Michigan has a
student run station, WCBN.
>> Susan Douglas: CBN, yeah.
>> And it's been on
the air for 50 years.
It's claim to fame was
for playing It's my Party
and I'll Cry if I want to
when Ronald Reagan was elected
[laughter] for 24
hours in a row.
It was the.
24 hours. But, as part
of Michigan's bicentennial
celebrations, the archives,
the paper archives of the, of
the radio station were collected
and deposited in the
Bentley Historical Library
and a lot of, a lot of WCBN.
They've moved.
Connecting the dots between
college radio and podcasting,
they've moved much of their,
of their work to podcast.
They have a podcast server.
You can look it up
as WCBN podcast.
And so, what goes over the
radio then becomes podcasts
and they think of
production in the, in,
mentally as podcasting first.
That happens to be
broadcast first
and then archived
on a podcast server.
So, it's alive and living.
And I think that
this is the situation
with a lot of college radios.
But, anyway.
I just wanted to, I didn't.
>> Susan Douglas: Do
they have official.
Yeah, I know about BCN.
But do they have official, you
know, university support and a?
>> Yes they do, it's
based out of,
it's funded by Literature,
Science and the Arts.
>> Susan Douglas:
LS and A funds, huh?
>> Yes. And the radio
station is in the basement
of the LS and A building.
>> Susan Douglas: Yeah.
>> So, yeah, anyway.
>> I just wanted to add a little
bit to the whole concept of,
you know, digitization
and radio is dying.
In America we're
actually pretty lucky,
in that we have a shitty digital
radio system called HD radio.
It is spectrally intensive.
It does not provide a
qualitative improvement
over analog broadcasting
and it's wholly proprietary,
meaning that you actually have
to pay a private
company a licensing fee
to adopt the radio technology.
Fortunately, the FCC back in the
early 2000's made the adoption
of the digital radio
standard wholly voluntarily,
wholly voluntary and
driven by the marketplace.
And the marketplace has
pretty much rejected HD radio,
less than 15 percent
of all licensed broadcasters
have actually adopted the
technology and the platform
itself has been sold
from its parent company
and it's now part
of a larger intellectual
property conglomerate
that doesn't really care that
much about radio broadcasting.
So, HD radio and the
digital transition of radio
in the United States
is something
that can be actively
resisted on many fronts.
And I'd also kind of like to
make a plea for the analog,
since digital radio transition
in the United States is
not working very well,
there is something to be said
for reclaiming analog
spectrum for community use.
Analog radio is not trackable.
It's not part of the panopticon,
like social media is.
And for people that are
very involved in activism,
that's a very useful
tactical tool
and the FCC does not
have the authority,
nor has it really had
the full authority
to actually enforce the
broadcast license requirement.
So, yesterday I was talking in
one of the panels about the fact
that in the place where
I live, New York City,
there are more unlicensed
FM radio stations
on the air right now, than there
are licensed FM radio stations.
So, those of you who are
interested in media activism
and social movements, I would
strongly suggest that you look
at radio as a mechanism
for tactical organization
and communication.
And it's a fairly simple risk
assessment to do and it actually
in my view has been a key
component to the revitalization
of radio as a community
building exercise
and I think that's
going to continue
for the foreseeable future.
>> Michele Hilmes: [Inaudible].
Thank you.
>> Thank you very much.
I'm Janie Doctor
[assumed spelling].
I've done a lot of work
on both British radio
and also American radio.
And I agree with a lot
of what's been said.
In teaching American
students about radio,
it's very interesting when they
hear the word radio they are
immediately turned off.
And I find that when I start
introducing them to some
of what's happening
around the world,
in actually broadcast radio and
I start actually showing them
that you can access that and
you can hear the creative space
that radio is and
all that's going
on in the really
lively discussions.
And some of what's
actually starting to happen
as we're talking about not
in what they think of radio,
which is Clear Channel or
whatever it's called these days,
but actually radio
as creative space.
Then all of a sudden, they
are excited and they love it.
And that's what they
think of as podcasts.
So, I think part of this
is a language issue.
They want to be involved
with that creative space.
They don't want to be
involved with what they think
of as old fashioned radio.
So, I do think part of it, I
love the sound work concept,
because I think, I do think
we have a language issue.
I love radio.
I'm from that generation.
But I know that when I'm trying
to get through to my students
and get them to take my courses,
I have to include Spotify,
I have to include all these.
I have to say, I'm talking
about an expanded
definition of what radio is.
Don't think of it as
what you think it is,
let's talk about
what it is today.
And then they, if I
bring them along with me,
then all of sudden they
want to be a part of it.
And they want to help, they
want to create within it.
So, I think if, if we're
going to go in the future,
I do think we have to think
of the semantics of it,
but I also think we have
to think of it as creative.
That's what they want.
They want it to be a
space that's creative.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Alexander Russo: I
think we have time for two
or three more questions.
>> I just had one,
just one comment.
In the. The unique strength
of broadcast radio is it's
not just bring information
to people vertically, it's
the horizontal conversations
that is unique to
live broadcast.
>> Michele Hilmes: Yeah.
>> Garrett Horton:
Garrett Horton
from Concordia University,
Portland Oregon.
In connection with what has
just been said, I was wondering
if people, anybody in the
room can point to studies
that have connected this, these
developments to mediatization,
as a theoretical concept because
I've dabbled a little bit
in the notion of mediatization,
the idea that, you know,
our world is becoming
ever more saturated and,
and defined by media and
mediatization scholars.
I want to point out
that, you know,
there's all these
various new developments
and mediatization
is a development
like globalization
like many others.
And it might also help us to
maybe update and bring sort
of this discussion into a,
you know, a broader context
that tries to define influence
of media in the current world.
And mediatization might
just be a way to do that.
>> Susan Douglas: I guess,
you know, thinking about this
from a teaching point of
view, you know what so many
of us are grappling with now and
seeking to revise our courses
around is this very
phenomenon and the ways
in which our students are
so constantly bombarded by
and engaged in with
screens all the time,
that it's actually difficult
for them to stand back
and see how much they
are in a mediatized world
or whatever the correct
way to describe it is.
And so, I'm in the process
of revising our big
introductory course now.
And I have to start with the,
all of the different ways
in which they are engaged
with and bombarded by screens.
That is very different from,
you know, when, 20 years ago.
And work back from that to
get them to then stand back
and really see the ocean
that they're swimming in.
>> Michele Hilmes:
So, that's it.
We have to.
Oh, we're getting the.
Thank you all.
[ Applause ]
>> Delores Ins
Casillas: Great.
Thank you to this session.
This is an ideal significant
and very rare session
to have in general.
Increasingly rare
and significant
because we are trying to make
a concerted effort to focus
on Spanish language radio
or broadcasting in Spanish
or multi-lingually within
the geographical boundaries
of the United States.
We are definitely in solidarity
with all these other significant
and important panels
taking place right now
at the same time.
The African American
radio panel,
as well as a podcasting
digital panel.
Despite startling growth and
the increasing use of Spanish,
there's still very little
scholarly attention, mainstream
or popularity attention
that's given to this medium.
Today, I'm very happy to
be a part of this panel
with these amazing panelists.
I am Delores Ins Casillas.
I am at the University of
California Santa Barbara.
And I write on Spanish
language radio broadcasting.
I've been doing that
for the past 10 years.
We also have Mari Castaeda,
who's Chair of Communications
at the University of
Massachusetts at Amherst.
There is one book that, the
first book that was written
on Spanish language radio
was published in 1978.
The second book was
mine in 2014.
But between those
two publications,
Mari Castaeda published a
piece in 2003 in the Journal
of Radio Audio Studies that
really revitalized this field
of study for Spanish
language radio.
It's considered a
[inaudible] piece in the field.
We also have Amalia Crdova,
who's a Latino digital curator
with Smithsonian Folk Life at
Washington D.C., who is going
to be talking a lot about in
Spanish indigenous bilateral
broadcasting in the
U.S. And Hugo Morales,
who we heard yesterday
at our public media
50th anniversary panel,
who did not receive the kind
of introduction that I felt
that he definitely merited
given his decades of work,
constructing [foreign language],
which is the largest bilingual
Latino public radio network
in the country, known to some
as a Spanish speaking
NPR of the United States.
We also have Rosa
Ramn, who's a cofounder
of KDMA FM in Washington.
She is known as one of
the pioneering women
on the Pacific Northwest
who encouraged Chicanas
to be radio producers
and radio hosts.
And in turn that changed
the programming we listen to
and the culture of a
lot of radio stations.
Monica de la Torre who's an
assistant professor transborder
studies at Arizona State
University has dedicated
actually her studies to
KDMA FM in Washington
and has constructed a
phenomenal online archive
of that radio station.
We also have Magaly Rivera,
who's the Executive Director
of the Latino Public Radio
Consortium and right now
in speaking from the
previous [inaudible]
where it's speaking a
little bit about analog
and community activism and the
Latino Public Radio Consortium
is key right now in trying
to keep radio stations
on the air in Puerto Rico.
She's key in trying to
rebuild radio stations there
and as a reminder, even
though Hurricane Maria hit
over a month ago, there's
still only 80 percent
of the Island has electricity,
but the radio station
that ran an analog was the
one that was broadcasting.
And lastly, we have Joy Hayes,
who's the associate professor
of Communications at
the University of Iowa,
also wrote a phenomenal
book called Mexico Nation,
which was the first
book in English
to really document the
significance of broadcasting
in Mexico as it built
its nation.
And she will be our
discussant today.
It really is a start
studded kind of panel
and it probably would've
been like the kind
of panel I would have envisioned
as a dream panel 10 years ago.
Before we begin, I do
want to remind people
that Spanish dominant Latino's
listen the most to radio.
And this is a demographic
that we actually don't
pay a lot of attention to.
Much more so than
English dominant listeners
or African American Listeners.
In fact, a listener profile
I like to remind people
that the average Spanish
language radio listener earns 35
thousand dollars a year.
And I feel like I need to
remind an NPR crowd of that.
And as someone who definitely
struts around in my NPR t-shirt
as well, it's very cognizant
of the very different
demographic of listeners.
Listeners tune in three hours.
Latino listeners tune in
three hours longer a week
than the general, which was code
for white English
radio listener.
They listen much earlier.
They tune in usually at 4 AM in
the morning, rather than 5:30
or 6 AM when we hear
early morning hosts.
And in my research and
elsewhere I've written
about how the majority of Latino
listeners take their radio sets
to work with them.
And we know this when we
pass a construction site.
We know this when use a bathroom
at the back of a restaurant.
I knew this, this morning
when the radio was coming
out of my hotel housekeepers
cart
when she was walking
down the hall.
It is a part of our everyday
landscape in the United States,
whether we recognize it or not.
And given the fact that it
is a working class medium,
I really try and advocate
that it's also a very kind
of brown collar way
of listening.
It's not something
that we listen
in the solitary confinements
of our car when we commute.
And it's definitely something
that's much more a public form
of listening because
of immigrants.
So, with that, we are going
to get started with
Mari Castaeda.
[ Applause ]
>> Mari Castaeda:
Thank you, Ins,
for that wonderful
introduction of the panel
and all of us here today.
Thank you all for making time.
I want to just thank the
organizers for this gathering,
especially Josh who
invited way back in the day
to really start thinking about
this issue a few years ago.
I was helping out with sort of
the archiving that was happening
in New England and particularly
Western Massachusetts.
I'm only going to speak
for a few minutes,
because I really do want
to recognize our panelists
and the limited time
that we have here today.
And this in itself could
be its own conference
of gathering of folks.
There's many more of
us that are starting
to really examine these issues
and really think
about the archiving.
I just wanted to highlight this
particular sort of website.
It's a piece that I wrote called
New England Latino [foreign
language] Through
Spanish Language Radio,
the case of WFCR
[foreign language].
And WFCR is actually
an NPR affiliate
in Western Mass that's
located in the five colleges,
which includes U-Mass Amherst,
Smith College, Hampshire,
Mount Holyoke and
Hampshire College,
and Amherst College as well.
And one of the things
that's really important
about this particular
program it's
that it's the only
Spanish language program
that started the late 70's,
early 80's that is still
continuously broadcast as a show
in Western Massachusetts and
given what's happened with Maria
in Puerto Rico and we have
a very large concentration
of [foreign language] in the
Western Massachusetts area.
This particular program has
increasingly become very
important more recently, in
terms of sharing information
of what's going on in the area
and also the relocation
that's happening of a lot
of folks coming back
from the island.
You know, so, in
terms of its presence,
it's still a very
important program.
But one of the things
that happened
as we started examining
archives across Western Mass
and across New England was
that the question of, you know,
what archives are
worthy of preservation
and how are they preserved.
And [foreign language] the
original producer, who is here,
is Luis Alfonso Melendez,
who now actually lives
in Puerto Rico and was
central in the creation
of Radio Vieques, as well.
And so, now there's a new
producer that's in charge
of the [foreign language].
But one of the things
that we started talking
about was the fact that
he had all these archives
of cassette tapes of the
program that he had done
because the station itself
was not necessarily recording
or preserving the programs that
were happening at the time.
And so, he as a radio producer
took on, upon himself to try
to record as much as possible
some of the cassette tapes,
I mean some of the programs
that were happening
through cassettes.
And so, he has these boxes and
boxes and boxes of programs
that actually included
conversations, for instance,
about freeing Oscar
Lopez that, you know,
he was recently freed
over the summer.
And the importance of those
conversations and mobilization
that was happening
even back in the 90's.
And. But one of the
challenges that we found was
that even though
universities, including U-Mass,
were interested in the archive,
you know, one of the things
that they made very clear was
that you can't just give us
a box and then we're going
to put it away in a sort
of room and that's it.
That there's, the archival work
really does require someone
that has to go in and really
listen to the program,
take notes, really examine
what's going on with it?
What are the various different
sort of themes and topics
and the conditions
of the cassettes
and the various different pieces
of the programming
that were recorded?
And so, it's been
a big challenge
because of the limited resources
that some of the libraries have.
The limited, you know, the fact
that there's very limited folks
in that region that speak
fluently in Spanish,
in terms of being able to really
transcribe what is happening
with regards to those programs.
And so, one of the things that
I have been trying to do is work
with some of my students that
are fluent Spanish speakers
as part of a course, community
engagement course to try
to really document that
particular archive to make sure
that the conversations that
really have shaped a lot
of New England and particularly
Western New England [foreign
language] and conversations
about the fact
that there's a large Puerto
Rican community that's been
there since the 40's
and increasingly also [foreign
language] that are relocating
to the region because
of agriculture
and particularly
the tobacco fields.
That again, [foreign
language] has been historically
very important.
Here we go.
Has been historically been
very important in helping sort
of think about the
community itself
and so I just wanted
to put it up there.
So, I just want to just note
this because there's a lot
of work that still needs to be
done and I think the question
of again, whose archives
are worth preserving?
And how are they preserved?
And what kind of resources
are being put in there?
became very clear in the
process of both looking
at [foreign language] and
various different archives
in Western Mass, specifically
serving communities of color
that have been ignored,
that have not been taken
into account, that don't
have the resources to be able
to really sort of
preserve them in the way
that they deserve
to be preserved.
And in fact, one of the things
that came up in the course
of trying to think
about what was happening
with this particular
archive and others,
is that we were literally
sometimes, oftentimes confronted
with folks just saying,
you know,
is this really that important?
You know, is it worth
the resources to pour
into this particular
type of archive?
It's going to, you know,
it's going to cost hundreds
of thousands of dollars perhaps,
definitely lots of
hours of labor.
And is it something that
is worth preserving.
And, of course, our
argument was yes, absolutely.
A lot of the programming that
was happening particularly
in [foreign language] is
really documenting the history
of Latinos in Western
Massachusetts
and in the New England area
because they were not just
focusing on Western Mass,
but also about the migration
of folks to the Northeast
and so really had both
regional, national
and transnational conversations
because sometimes Luis was also
actually phoning in with folks
in Puerto Rico and Mexico and
different parts of Latin America
about what was happening
in those areas and how
that was impacting U.S. Latinos
as well because, of course,
the connections that
were happening
between communities are not as
sort of separate as sometimes,
oftentimes people
assume them to be.
And so, really trying to
think about, you know, again,
whose archives are we
really emphasizing.
I'm struck that oftentimes
we're not really thinking
about communities of color and
the archives that do exist,
but what kind of resources do
we have to make those available
to other people because of
the rich cultural history
that actually does exist in
these, in these programs.
And so, this is one of the
projects that I am working
on trying to really
document that.
But there's a lot of work to
do and a lot of other projects
and I know that a
lot of my friends
and colleagues here
are engaged with that.
But I really want us to think
a little bit more deeply
about how do we actually
make that effort
to really include those
archives in these conversations.
For instance, this program
should be part of the Library
of Congress, should be
documented and preserved.
And why is it not happening?
How do we make that
happen is the thing I want
to conclude with.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
[ Inaudible ]
>> Amalia Crdova: Full screen.
I need my presenter
notes from you.
Okay [inaudible].
Okay great.
[Foreign language].
Good morning.
I like starting multi-lingually
because my life is that way.
And I want to thank
the conference
for putting this together.
I also want to acknowledge
the Pescado Nation
on whose land we're
gathered today.
I wanted to talk
about other languages
in the [foreign language]
and I thought I would start
with an event that
happened as a side event
of the U.N. Permanent
Forum on Indigenous Issues,
which is held every year.
And in 2015 in the
spring, a student of NYU
of Quechua Language Program
organized the transnational
voices panel of indigenous
radio broadcasters.
Three of them were broadcasting
in the New York City area.
One of them, [foreign
language] was visiting.
She's a very famous well known
[family history] broadcaster.
So, it was an occasion to
actually have a conversation
around the different
languages that are spoken
in the Northeast again and
specifically in New York City,
which happens to be the city
with the largest
indigenous population
of all the United States if
you combine indigenous people
from all over the world,
not just the continental
United States.
So, [foreign language] who runs
First Voices Indigenous Radio,
which is the stable indigenous
North American radio show
in New York City on
Pacifica Network,
gave introductory remarks
working with [foreign language],
who used to work with the WBAI,
which is another
Pacifica affiliate,
and the morning program.
And [foreign language]
who is Quechua
and who is a radio
broadcaster who was working
on Spanish language radio,
but then he met Charlie
and he met other people
who were working in Quechua
and they decided to put together
a Quechua language radio show
in New York, a weekly
online broadcast program.
And the two other broadcasters
are [foreign language]
from Mexico.
So, how does Quechua become,
start to scan across
New York City.
There's a Quechua program
funded by [inaudible] funding
of the Department of Education
under the Foreign Language
and area studies funding.
And so, the students
of the Quechua program are
learning Quechua as part
of their foundational
academic training.
But they know there's
a community out there
and so increasingly
the program is not just
about having a language
lessons on the campus,
but getting language speakers
from across the tri state area
to come in and hear different
variants and really think
of Quechua as a living language
and as a language that's
around you, not somewhere
in a remote place.
So, there are weekly workshops
open to the community.
There are podcasts being
created by the students
so they can listen and hear
and practice their Quechua.
And there are community
gatherings.
So, we already have this kind
of soundscape happening
around us at NYU.
And I was at that time the
assistant director of the Center
for Latin American
Studies at NYU.
And so, these three
Quechua speakers,
because Charlie [inaudible] is
a second generation Ecuadorian,
and his parents were
not really investing
in him learning Quechua.
That was seen as
something to leave behind.
And when he said, I want to
study Quechua and I'm going
to learn Quechua at NYU,
he was like why are you using
your credits this way, right?
So, it's, it's a
whole sort of work
to legitimize the
language again,
as again a contemporary language
and a language that's around us.
So, the radio show was
a wonderful way for them
to get together [foreign
language] got together.
And [foreign language] had
already this wonderful radio
experience, built the studio
that you see now in a basement
of a building in the Bronx.
And this is how Kichwa Hatari
begins, by just doing it
and bringing the
community together.
And they broadcast in Spanish
and Quechua, sometimes in Kichwa
and sometimes in
English depending
on who their guests are.
So, as a programming of the
Folklife Festival last year,
we really wanted to bring
these kind of initiatives
and this kind of
work to them all.
So, we built a little
station called,
during our program
called On the Move.
We were talking about migration
in the United States as part
of a 50th anniversary.
We had a media production
setup, really, really barebones.
I don't know if you've been to
the festival, but we have it
on the mall and then
take it down.
So, there are no hard walls.
It's all just tarp
and two by fours.
So, we build this media
studio on the mall.
And we invited Kichwa Hatari
to be our resident
media collective.
So, they basically, when
we were planning this,
I was thinking how are
you going to do this
and when they told me the
activities they were thinking,
I was like you're
basically bringing the studio
onto the mall, right?
So, that's what they did.
So, this was them intervening
this blackboard that we put.
They brought the [foreign
language], the flag.
And, of course, we
also had other programs
with the local Andean
community, which is huge here
around the D.C. Virginia area.
So, thinking about the people I
was bringing, I was very excited
to think that there
would be all these,
all these cross references.
So, Kichwa Hatari ends
up interviewing the
[foreign language] team
or the dance troupe
that we brought
of different Bolivian
[inaudible] dancers.
And in Quechua, in
Kichwa, right,
depending on who they were
bringing, mostly Quechua,
interviewing a local
DJ who's Bolivian,
whose grandfather spoke Quechua.
And just producing these
new relationships and they
like this idea of the
popup so much that.
We called it the mixing room.
That's what this little
space that you see behind.
We call that the mixing room.
And it was an open air studio
and they like this idea so much
that they're now doing this
in other festivals and events.
This was kind of the first
time they took the studio out.
So, they have a page on the
Smithsonian Folklife website.
You can go visit it and
learn a little bit more
about their work.
Another thing they did
was offer Quechua class.
On the, in the bottom row
in the middle you see five
[foreign language] doing an open
air Quechua, Kichwa
class for the public.
And we were able to get
this out and people came.
They actually got an audience.
We were having interviews
of the participants come
through this open air studio.
We have students come through.
And at the end of the day,
they would just get together
and do some music right there
on the mall after hours.
So, they really took over the
space and this is just a way
to show how, how you can bring
the liveness of radio out
and into the air and consider
it in your programming.
That it's not just
something that has
to stay in a digital medium.
You can show people the
value of this engagement
and they really did a great
job by bringing things
like the [foreign
language], the Andean flag.
Things like brining the Quechua,
the Kichwa class methodology,
by bringing the music,
by DJing on site.
So, they really spilled over
their kind of usual format
of two hour broadcast on Friday.
And this is, this is
something that really was easy
to incorporate into our thinking
around a live presentation
on the mall open air
public presentation.
So, they broadcast [foreign
language] every Friday six
to eight.
The episodes are archived on
the Kichwa Hatari website.
It's in Spanish and in Quechua.
Little pieces are
in English too.
They have a Facebook page,
where they're regularly
posting the events
that they are starting to
travel in different places.
So, they've been to Havana
to the [foreign language]
to a conference there on radio.
They're really getting
attention.
And they have a Twitter
handle Kichwa Hatari.
So, I just wanted to
bring up the importance
of thinking outside of
just Spanish language.
Spanish is a bridge to
other constituencies.
And I think what they're
also, what Kichwa Hatari
and other collectives are
doing is creating this diasp,
we're bringing together this
[inaudible] of people who,
because of the jobs
and the migration
and sometimes documentation
status
and just geographic remoteness,
they'll come together
and through the radio, they're
bringing together this language
community, which ends up
being a cultural community.
So, that's how important
this is.
And also people are using the
radio program as an entry point
into language revitalization.
So, by listening and hearing
Quechua and Kichwa bilingually,
broadcast bilingually, people
have started to also realize
that they understand or be
interested and say I want
to speak better, I want
to gain fluency, right.
So, this is part of the project.
Their website really
explains their mission well.
They talk about Andean
world view.
They talk about the language.
But they also talk about
the living community.
And I'll be happy to
take questions later.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
[ Inaudible ]
>> Hugo Morales: Buenos Diaz.
Good morning.
So, Hugo Morales, I'm
Hugo Morales and I want
to tell you a little bit about
the history of Radio Bilingue
and then proceed to give
you a little bit of an idea
about what it is already
archived here at the Library
of Congress of Radio Bilingue.
So, I'm Hugo Morales.
I'm co-founder of
Radio Bilingue.
Thank you, Ines,
for inviting me.
And I'm looking forward
to Rosa Ramn's story.
She's been a real force
in public broadcast,
particularly community radio.
So, you know, Radio Bilingue
was founded in 1976 and we went
on the air on July 4th, 1980.
And we chose July 4th,
1980 because we wanted
to affirm the fact that
we're U.S. citizens,
the fact that we too
should have a space
in the airwaves of this country.
We wanted to be recognized.
We also wanted to express
and exercise our First
Amendment rights.
That's why founded Radio
Bilingue and we chose July 4th.
And so, it's, it's really
important to note that date,
at least for me, a cofounder,
that when we founded
Radio Bilingue there were
about 15 million
Latinos in the U.S.,
which is about 6.5 percent
share of the U.S. population.
And we're now at 58 million
in the U.S. and 18 percent
of the general population.
According to the [inaudible]
Trust just this week,
they put out 72 percent of us
Latinos speak Spanish at home.
So, I think the importance
of a Spanish language media
is not something that is like,
it shouldn't be anyway,
on the back burner,
but rather something that
folks should pay attention to.
It's a lot of folks.
And in California, essentially,
I don't think you can get
anything past the California
Legislature now without
the pen of a Latino,
because we control the Senate
and we control the Assembly.
So, nothing goes through.
So, that's, that's
where we've come.
But I want to talk about Radio
Bilingue has played a part today
in, you know, it's played
a part in the development
and history particularly
of California,
but, but just in general.
We have the same values as
the public broadcasters.
We are part of the public
broadcasting family.
We believe in the integrity
of, of what we put on the air.
We don't accept money
from tobacco companies
or liquor companies,
or anybody who's
in the AFL-CIO boycott list.
We understand that our
community is vulnerable.
Our, you know, the, our
core audience earns less
than 35 thousand a year.
Our core audience probably has
like a high school
education or less.
So, you know, we, that's
why we have these policies
and we also don't play
[foreign language]
and we don't promote
drugs or violence.
And that includes
violence against women.
So, and we also don't,
don't allow any of our songs
to be played that in any
way degrade, you know,
gays and lesbians and so
on, which is very common
in commercial Spanish
language media.
And so, what we do in public
affairs and we the founders
from the beginning thought
the heart of our and sole
of our [foreign language] or
obviously [foreign language]
and so we are not
Spanish speaking only.
We're bilingual.
So that's why it's
Radio Bilingue.
And to be correct,
actually, now it should be
like Radio Multilingue,
I mean because we are
in fact also broadcasting
indigenous languages
like [foreign language], which
is the language of my people.
I'm a [foreign language]
immigrant.
And also, we also broadcast
in [foreign language]
in our full power FM
station in Salinas.
And so, that, that
station broadcast
to the [foreign language]
population because it too
within the context of
indigenous in Mexico
or the Americas is among
the most vulnerable.
There's only about 40 or 50
thousand [foreign language]
and about five thousand
are in, within our,
within a service
area in Salinas.
And then, in terms of,
[foreign language],
there's about three million of
us and of course our homeland is
in the Northern part of the
state of [foreign language],
Southern part of
[foreign language].
But, anyway, in one
of our beats,
our beats include [inaudible],
which is typical of,
if you take out any,
how will I say, yeah,
surveys of what Latinos
are interested in.
We cover those.
You hear about education.
You hear about economic
opportunity.
You hear about immigration.
You talk about health access.
So, we cover those beats.
And, of course, we also cover
the arts and literature.
And so, if you look
at immigration
that has been something that
we have followed very closely
for a lot of reasons, including
that literally it's a
life changing situation
for many of our families.
Just in Fresno, the City
of Fresno and also LA,
one out of five children
in LA Unified
or Fresno Unified has one
or two undocumented parents.
I mean, that's, you know,
that gives you a sense
of the dimension of why right
now, for example, there's a lot
of fear among the
Latino community.
And that includes our audience.
So, if you look at, looking back
at Radio Bilingue's history,
we were there when we covered
the immigration debates,
you know, in the mid 80's,
leading to the Simpson-Rodino
Bill,
which equalized some
three million folks,
and which opened doors to
economic opportunities,
etcetera, etcetera and
coming out of the shadows.
So, Radio Bilingue provides
a daily forum, live forum.
We have a talk show called
[foreign language] that began
in 1995, which it literally,
it was modeled after Talk
of the Nation, that was part
of National Public Radio.
I think that was abandoned
like three or four years ago.
But, so, you get
a sense of that.
But, talk in Spanish,
particularly for our families,
is really, really critical.
It's something that, you
know, it's a way for people
to communicate, to
learn, etcetera.
And so, we also covered in
the 90's the backlash in some
of the places like in the
Midwest against the migration
of Mexicans and Latinos moving
into particularly the midwest.
So, we cover that and of course,
it's not just the Midwest.
California, Pete Wilson, and,
you know, and his, you know,
folks like him who pushed
for literally a proposal
and the proposal went
beyond that, a proposition
that effectively, you know,
got rid of, proposed to get rid
of services for the
undocumented.
Eventually, it lost
in the courts.
But that happened.
I guess that's a
representation of that.
And then, also the [inaudible]
of bilingual education
in our schools, that
passed and became law.
And we had no luck in getting
it overturned, until this year.
So, anyway, but that's something
that we covered [inaudible]
the hostility.
And now, of course, that we're
covering many triumphs of our,
within our legislature in
the State of California
that are very pro-Latino
and pro-immigrant.
We're a sanctuary
state, you know, where,
you know other cities
may struggle,
our entire state is a sanctuary.
So, those are some of the
things that we've covered.
And there's a degree of
identification and comfort.
But those that are understand
the mission of Radio Bilingue
and how important
Radio Bilingue is.
So, when Rosa Maria
Hernandez, an indigenous woman
from the State of Oaxaca,
where I'm from, you know,
when her child was
taken away at the birth
because she could not
speak Spanish or English
and therefore was considered
by the courts to not be fit
to be a mother and
mother her child.
We. It was an activist person
from the State of [inaudible]
who called Radio
Bilingue and asked
that we put that story out.
And we did and it became a
national mainstream story
including the New York Times
and eventually she
would recover child.
But that's, that's the.
By the way, we also get calls
like that from occasionally
from people who are cut
up, how would I say it?
Victims of the Narcos in Mexico.
That's something that also.
So, we're not just a recognized
as a Latino U.S. service,
but a transnational service.
In fact, we broadcast
in [foreign language]
and we have been since about
2000 by satellite all the way
to Oaxaca, our homeland.
On Sundays we take over
the airwaves in that way.
What I want to do is
also tell you like,
like what's in the archives
because already we do have some
of our, much of our content
on the archives at the Library
of Congress, who could use
some more help by the way
of some grad students
to finish the job.
But among the what's
in the archives now
and you can visit the
Library of Congress archives,
are the first day
broadcast of Radio Bilingue.
And it's interesting
how that came about.
Actually, we didn't
care about taping it.
It's interesting, right?
It was actually one
of our supporters,
who I didn't even know,
who he was actually the second
attorney, Mexican attorney,
Mexican American attorney in
the whole San Joaquin Valley,
whole central value, who got
his tape recorder and taped it.
And about two years
ago, before his death,
gave it to Radio Bilingue.
And that's how it's saved.
So, and then for the first
10 years, we actually used,
because of the economic
situation,
we literally had a bulking
machine where we erased programs
on tape because of
economic reasons.
We didn't think about
preserving.
But obviously, now
we know the value.
And now, we're literally taping
every second of our broadcast.
And then we have the
Simpson-Rodino law reform.
We had a whole series on that.
A symposium on Ernesto Galarza.
I don't know if any one of you
knew who Ernesto Galarza was?
He was a community organizer and
[foreign language] by the way,
had a doctorate as well
and it was very interested
in the [foreign language]
program.
And it was actually he who was
some say he was responsible
for raising awareness
about the expectation
of [foreign language] and that's
why, you know, it was erased
from being a U.S. program.
We have interviews with
[foreign language], for example,
in our studios, [foreign
language], and these are,
how would I say,
traditional music stars.
[Foreign language] from
Arizona and then California.
And then we also have
[foreign language], you know,
traditional music, you
know, accordion player.
Bert Corona, another community
organizer, [foreign language]
and then went on to California.
And so on.
And so, we have,
you know, a lot of,
of voices including
those of our listeners.
And that's something
that we pride a lot,
take a lot of pride in.
I wanted to just quote,
because we do have
over the air fundraising.
And even though our listeners do
not have much disposal income,
we do every year for about
a week we get on the air,
just like other public
radio stations and ask
for financial support.
So, there's some notes that
I want to read from some
of the people that when asked
why do you want to make,
you know, a 35 dollar
contribution.
And from Crystal City, Texas,
where we have a radio station,
you'll hear something like
well this is [foreign language]
from Crystal, this is Radio
Bilingue a communication
channel, it has helped me a lot.
It identifies itself
with the poor,
humble people and
with immigrants.
It is a blessing
and a reflection
of what is going on here.
And then, another one, it says,
Rosa [foreign language]
says I'm a huge fan
of the [foreign language]
show, which is on Saturdays.
Radio Bilingue is one of
the few public stations
that really lives up to
its mission with a mix
of information, music and PSA's.
And so, and then another one
says, Carmen from Riverdale,
I greatly appreciate Radio
Bilingue's programming,
especially your information
programs.
I have learned a lot by
listening to Radio Bilingue.
I also like that you treat
people with much respect.
So, with that, what
I want to do is,
let's see if we can
play the audio.
Do I do it here, or?
>> [Music] are you
scanning through the radio?
You just made the right choice.
You're listening
to Radio Bilingue.
[ Foreign language ]
>> This is a big deal, isn't
it for Imperial County,
for all of California, I
suppose, juvenile justice.
[ Foreign language ]
>> You're not thinking
about eating those 22 packs
of sugar, are you, honey?
>> Why not, Mom.
You drink them every day.
>> What are you talking about?
[ Foreign language ]
>> We have a great
listening audience
and they know their music
in mariachi, oldies,
[foreign language], salsa,
[foreign language]
and so much more.
We are.
>> Radio Bilingue.
>> Thank you.
>> Hugo Morales:
Thank you so much.
[ Applause ]
>> Monica de la Torre:
Good morning everybody.
My name is Monica de la Torre
and I am honored to be here
with this amazing panel
of Spanish language
and multilingual radio
and I'm especially honored
to be sitting next to Rosa
Ramn, one of the cofounders,
the only woman cofounder
of Radio KDNA,
the nation's first full time
Spanish language noncommercial
radio station in
the United States
that was founded,
went on air in 1979.
And was, just completely
revolutionized the ways
in which we understand Spanish
language radio, particularly
when it comes to intentionally
incorporating women
into broadcasting as producers,
as news directors,
as station manager.
Rosa was the first station
manager of Radio KDNA.
And so, today, I'm just
going to go briefly
into our work together
in attempting to archive
and preserve the
history of Radio KDNA.
It is located in
Granger, Washington,
which is in Eastern Washington.
And it's the agricultural hub of
the area, a lot of farm workers,
especially Spanish speaking,
Mexican, Mexican American,
Chicanos that beginning
in the 1950's migrated
to the Pacific Northwest
to work in the hops,
apples, cherries, asparagus.
You name it, they're there.
So, it's important for me to
particularly bring awareness
to the fact that women have been
from the beginning
a vital component
of community radio production.
And this is an image here.
I'm going to go through some of
the images that we've been able
to digitize and because
of Rosa's efforts right
from the beginning to document
and preserve and the history
of the station, KDNA
has a really rich visual
and sonic archive.
And so, this is an image
here, you see Rosa also there
in the image sitting on the
truck constructing the tower
on [inaudible] Ridge,
right outside of Granger.
And this is a map of the
work that Radio KDNA did
from the beginning to
begin to address the lack
of Spanish language
news in broadcasting.
Prior to this, Spanish language
news was translated from English
and didn't really
speak to the issues
that communities
were interested in.
And so, Radio KDNA and their
organizing efforts beginning
in 1975 created the Spanish
language news network
that you see here a map
of all the different
radio stations both,
that included commercial
stations of how they were able
to create and produce news and
Rosa can probably speak better
about this than I can.
But, here is another image
of the radio station now.
And you see here the
logo, the farm worker,
that is really vital to
Radio KDNA as being the voice
of the farmer [foreign
language].
And so, I wanted to play
really quickly a clip of one
of the women that was involved
in the radio trainee program,
[foreign language], who speaks
about what it meant to her
to learn broadcasting, but also
to have the support of women.
So, I'll play that.
And then I'll let
Rosa speak for a bit.
>> [Music].
[Foreign language]
was born in Mexico.
She is a wife and a mother to
a young five-year-old child.
A farm worker for most
of her young 23 years,
[foreign language] experience
with Radio KDNA began
as a trainee in radio
broadcasting.
Now, she is Radio KDNA's
Public Affairs producer.
>> Being a public affairs
producer is exciting.
Some of the things I have
to do is screen three
to four newspapers a
day for news relevant
to the Chicano community, plus
information and news releases
that come into the
station daily.
I also cover local news
story, which require research,
interviews, attending
meetings and press conferences.
Then, I have to write my scripts
for the two news
programs I produce.
Producing news takes a lot of
time, plus raising a family,
but my family is
very understanding.
My daughter sometimes
is very proud of me.
She tells all her friends that
her mommy's a disk jockey.
My families very proud of me
too, because they can't believe
that I'm working
in a radio station.
I thought that I better get into
something else besides farm work
and I thought I would
give my parents something
to be proud of, to being in a
radio station and be a mother
and raise a family and
work at the same time.
And work at the same time.
And do something that
will help the community.
I plan to take some
classes for communications.
The very first time I did the
news live, it was my first time,
I was very, very nervous.
And after my news was
over, I came out and Rosa
and Estella were waiting
for me at the door
and they were applauding me.
And that made me feel really
good because I get a lot
of support from them and I think
that's what keeps me going.
>> Monica de la Torre: So, I
love that clip for many reasons.
One, we hear, to be able to
hear [foreign language] voice.
Some of the programming that's
specifically was about women
that Radio KDNA had a program
called [foreign language] Woman.
A lot of those shows, as
Hugo mentioned earlier,
are not archived because
of a lack of resources.
A lot of the tapes were reused.
And so, to be able to
have this, this gem of,
being able to listen to
[foreign language] to talk
about how important it was for
her to get into broadcasting,
in very practical means
of finding different
employment outside
of farm work, I think
is important.
And then, the fact
that she doesn't have
to negotiate her different
identities as a mother,
as a woman, as somebody
that's interested in radio.
That all those aspects of her
identity were embraced and put
on air through the programming
and through her voice.
So, with that, I want
to hand it over to Rosa
and show you a few more images.
And I just want to say
how wonderful it's been
to work with Rosa.
I met her as a graduate
student and I interviewed her
for a project called
Women who Rock.
And it's an oral history project
that documents social activism
and music and other
sonic communities.
And the first time I met her, I
also have a background in radio
like a lot of us here.
And I just was so excited that
I had met another Chica that,
you know, paved the way
for someone like myself.
So, I'll let Rosa say a
little bit about the work
that we've doing in archiving.
She's been really instrumental.
We've gone to the station
together to look for things,
to look for programs, any sort
of archive that we can start
to preserve this really
important history.
>> Rosa Ramn: Hi, everybody.
I'm so glad that
you're joining us today.
And I hope that I
don't bore you.
When Monica approached
me, I tried to avoid her.
I was getting ready
to retire and thinking
of having the life
of ease, right?
And it was really her passion
for wanting to make sure
that this information
was recorded,
this story about Radio KDNA,
this story about the women,
because in much of the history
of the social movement women
actually, especially even
in the Chicana movement,
women have kind
of been left out of the picture.
And so, her enthusiasm
to make sure that all
of this was archived, was
recorded, was going to be
in a position to be shared,
inspired me to get busy
and to help her with
her project.
And I did not know at the time.
She mentioned the photography.
I did not know at the time when.
We were all quite young when
we started the radio station.
And I wasn't quite poor as well.
And one of the first things I
did when I had enough money was
to buy a camera, just
a little Minolta camera
that cost 100 bucks, which
then was a lot of money.
And so, I began to
photograph everything.
The. That's one of my pictures.
The one in the truck
is one of my pictures.
I photographed the station
from the beginning when we went
to visit KBBF in
Santa Rosa California,
which was the first bilingual
station in the country.
And we were, none of us
had experience in radio.
And so, we learned that there
was a station in Santa Rosa.
And so, we took a group of
us there to talk to them.
And so, I have photographs
from those earlier periods.
Also, because we were poor,
we did all of our construction
on our radio station by hand.
We did the tower.
We were not engineers, but
with the help of one engineer,
we got volunteers,
community volunteers.
So, it was really a station
that was built by the community.
So, we did the tower.
We put up the antenna.
We dug the holes
on the mountain.
Our tower is located on
Yakima National Tribal Land.
We worked with them on
getting a reasonable price.
And so, we did all
of the digging
and the moving of the rocks.
Everything was done by
hand for Radio KDNA.
It's a very special
radio station,
in that its way up
in the Northwest.
Many people didn't even know
there were Spanish people living
in the Northwest at the time.
And when the station first
went in the air, on the air,
our audience was
really not immigrants,
because the first arrivals to
do agriculture work in the State
of Washington were
American citizens, Texans,
people from California, people
from the Midwest that moved
into Washington State, but
primarily [foreign language].
And then, later on, as, of
course, immigration increases,
the station, of course, which
is one of the beautiful things
about radio is its flexibility
to be able to really focus
on the needs of its community.
It was able to then adjust
itself to meet the needs of,
you know, the immigrants that
were moving into the valley.
So, its programming has
changed over the years,
but initially it was
U.S. citizen Spanish
speaking audience.
So, that's just a little
bit of the history.
And to just put in
context why it's so rare
that this station actually
succeeded in the Northwest is
because that area is extremely
rural, poor, very agricultural,
very extremely conservative,
all of the political positions
are held by the agricultural,
representatives of the
agricultural industry.
And so, there was a lot of fear
about the station
coming into that area.
And just, I don't
want to say a lot
because there's just too much.
I woke up at three o'clock
this morning trying to think
of what I should say to
going back and looking
at this 50 year history.
And I though uh.
So, I just want to,
just give you,
just to give you one example
of what we dealt with.
I was invited to
speak to a religious.
The denomination doesn't matter.
But a religious group and one of
the questions that they asked me
in this interview, they
wanted to about Radio KDNA,
was what do we say to our
parishioners when they think
that your people are no
higher than the animals.
So, that was one of the
first questions that I dealt
with when our station
first went in the air.
So, it gives you an idea
of why it's so remarkable
that the first Spanish language
radio station should come
out of this tiny, poor town
in the State of Washington.
And that it has accomplished
what it has done.
In terms of one very
important issue tackling AIDS
within the Latino community.
It was horrible and there
wasn't any information going
out in Spanish.
Radio KDNA took that on and did
a national program in Spanish.
It did a radio drama
series in Spanish
to educate the Latino community.
So, that's, that's the kind of
station, you know, that it is.
And I don't want
to go on too long.
It's just too much.
But I thank you for being here.
And I'm happy to answer
any questions later too.
[ Applause ]
>> Delores Ins
Casillas: [Inaudible]
and then we'll have
Joy and then wrap it
up with Alex and
Caribbean radio.
Hold on a minute.
Sorry. [Inaudible].
Oh I think I do.
Oh no there it goes.
>> Magaly Rivera:
Good morning everyone.
Thank you so much
for being here.
I want to see this place filled.
I represent.
I'm the Executive Director the
Latino Public Radio Consortium
and we represent and service
over 50 Latino public
radio stations,
such as KDNA, Radio Bilingue.
And the services that we provide
to the station is working
towards their sustainability.
We host an annual Latino
summit, where we bring all
of the stations together.
And when you think of us
as a national organization
and you look at just the
two examples that you saw
of two very distinctive
long serving radio stations
and you look at radio stations
like Latino Public Radio
in [foreign language], which has
a large Puerto Rican population.
You look at WDNA, which is in
Miami, an all jazz station.
They put on the first Latino
jazz festival last year.
And then you look
at another one,
like Lancaster Pennsylvania
WLCH,
whose parent organization
has a tech center,
they have a senior
citizen center
and their radio station is very
well known in the community
and very well integrated.
And when you look at the role
that the consortium plays
in being a national umbrella,
we look at what are the
commonalities of support
that we can provide to them.
And so, for us, it lies
in collaboration,
talent and training.
And these three things
also are important
when we're talking
about preservation.
Yesterday, Jennifer Lawson
at the Pub Media 50th said
something that for me was so key
and so important and
I had to give a shout
out to her on Twitter.
And she said, preservation
national yes,
but let's not forget
local communities.
And that is so significant
and I'm going
to give you a very unfortunate
and vibrant picture of that.
And that relates to what is
happening in Puerto Rico.
We have five Latino
public radio stations
that have been dramatically
affected by the hurricane.
Obviously, preservation
and collection of all
of the historical
news information
that they hone has become a huge
and significant concern for us.
WIPR, who is a state
responder, is on air.
WRTU is working to get on air.
The consortium is very,
very fortunate to be working
in collaboration with
public media stations
that have come forward
to support.
There are still stations
that are off the air.
There are still stations whose
collections are not being air
conditioned, are not
being humidified.
And part of the work that
the consortium is doing is
to make sure that
we preserve that.
We're thankful, obviously,
to the Corporation
for Public Broadcasting.
They have been our major
funder since the acception
of the Latino Public
Radio Consortium.
They have played a major role
in providing emergency
funding to these stations.
And they have also
played a major role
in bringing forth stations
that can support us.
Coast Alaska had these
radio to go kits.
If you're not familiar
with them,
you can go up on Coast Alaska,
but they're ready to go kits
that they thought of when
they would have an emergency,
in terms of being able
to continue to broadcast.
And so, these type
of collaborations are
so significant when we're
speaking to the preservation
of news, when we're speaking
to the preservation of talent.
I'm not suggesting that we
take human bodies and put them
in preservations, but one of the
radio stations and I don't know
if you know this, I should
say one of the radio stations,
but there our dual broadcaster.
They ceased operations
indefinitely.
And on the same day that
they ceased operations,
they let go of all their staff.
We created a GoFundMe to be
able to help the stations.
But the question behind that
is, is that when you look
at the growth of public media
and you look at the work
that these stations do in the
local community, we all know
and just in the pictures that
she showed that in public media,
when you enter public media as a
talent, you start as a trainee,
you start as a volunteer.
Some of us are more fortunate
and start in specific roles,
but you have a tendency to
stay for a very long time.
Radio has that kind
of effect, no.
And so, our concerns
are with talent.
And the growth of Latino public
media with respect to being able
to look at that there
is the potential
that Latino radio stations
that are struggling
because they have one
or two team members,
because they have
volunteers that come and go,
because the universities
are not able to gear them
into public media
as a career path.
Now, I'm speaking to
Latino populations, right?
When you consider how long
and hard NPR has been working
to increase Latino talent, this
is all part of preservation.
And collaboration is
so significant to that.
As a consortium, we
serve over 50 stations.
We're a two people staff.
So, needless to say,
I don't sleep a lot.
And the other thing about
that is had it not been
for Coast Alaska to come forward
with the radio to go kits,
had it not been for WNYC to
offer their engineers to fly
to Puerto Rico to help WIPR FM
get back on air, had it not been
for WMFV Orlando, who delivered
the second radio kit and worked
with their own partners
to get a charter plane
to deliver the equipment.
The collaboration of
public media is significant
to the preservation of
Latino radio stations.
The local community and the
work and all of the news,
when you think about
the California fires,
I think of KBBF, one of the only
radio stations that was able
to cover information
and news in Spanish.
Okay. Radio Bilingue also did
a lot of important interviews.
They did so with
respect to Puerto Rico,
even though their population
is predominantly Mexican.
So, our role as a consortium is
to bring forth collaboration,
so that we can continue
to grow Latino media,
specifically radio.
When I think of KSVR, within
the CCPB, we support 11 stations
that are CSG qualified.
For that, that means
that is the funding
that the corporation
provides to us.
They are our predominant funder.
So, we are required
to specifically service
those 11 stations.
We have 50 that want
to be serviced.
And so, the collaboration
of entities that come forth,
like WNYC, WMFE, are so
significant and when I look
at just public, the public media
system as a whole and our vision
to make it a more inclusive
public media, I would love
to see more partnerships.
I would love to see the
consortium contacted
by general market
stations to look at ways
to support our growth,
our local stations in all
of the different markets.
That is preservation of media.
To be able to look at
the current problems
that we're facing and you
spoke to Radio Vieques.
Radio Vieques is off air.
They have been off air.
However, they took a truck,
the put two speakers on it
and they have been roaming
throughout the island
of Vieques ensuring news,
ensuring information,
ensuring resources.
And we're hoping in
another week to be able
to issue a press release that
will give insight to our work
in getting Radio
Vieques back on air.
And interestingly enough, when
you look at Puerto Rico and all
of the different topics that
have surfaced with respect
to Puerto Rico being a
colony, am I a U.S. citizen?
Because yes I am Puerto Rican.
And the history of Puerto Rico,
you know, I don't know how many
of you know there is
the [foreign language],
which has over 100 years
of archival collections,
which is American history.
And the reason its
American history is
because Puerto Ricans
are American.
And I'm not being
[inaudible] in saying this.
I need to repeat it.
And because [foreign language]
was a very loved governor,
had a very close and
wonderful friendship
with Rockefeller,
Nelson Rockefeller.
There are letters
and videos and audios
and so much wonderful
information
that our radio stations go
to this foundation to obtain.
And through a separate
role, I was fortunate
to work very closely with
[foreign language] Foundation.
And I was in awe of the amount
of American history
that they have.
And I even wonder how many
of our public media stations
utilize it, know about it.
All of the stations in
Puerto Rico turn to them
when they're looking
for historical data.
So, my message, which I hope
that these very few of you
who are here in this
audience will take to all
of your colleagues is the
consortium needs collaborations.
The, KSVR, which I
started to mention before
and my mind deviated
for a moment,
in Mount Vernon has
a growing population.
And they're thwarted because
they're limited in their ability
to provide content and
they air in English.
And they don't only air
to a Latino audience.
So, my question is, how do I
sit sleepless nights trying
to figure out how I help KSVR
enhance their programming
when there is a wealth of
public media system executives
with talent, expertise,
knowledge, content.
And so, that's my message.
I would love to see our local
community stations continue
to thrive.
I would love to know that our
Puerto Rico stations do not have
to cease operations.
That despite what has
happened with the hurricane
that there are ways and the
only way that that can happen is
through the support
of our colleagues.
That's the only way.
Am I past my time?
[Inaudible].
Okay. Thank you.
I really thank you so much.
If you really want to know
who our radio stations are,
on our website, when
you go to publications,
there's a publication
called a snapshot.
It gives a very detailed insight
on each single radio station.
If you want to know how you can
help our Puerto Rico stations,
on our homepage there's
a GoFundMe.
But there is also a list of
all of the different things
that we're doing to help bring
the Puerto Rico stations back
to full capacity.
We know we will get them back
on air on a short term basis.
But we need the public
media system to be able
to help not only Puerto Rico,
but all of our radio stations.
So, thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> We might not have time
for questions right now
because I want to give time
for the Caribbean
[inaudible] to speak.
[Inaudible].
I hope we can all stick around.
>> Joy Hayes: Alrighty.
Well, it's my pleasure
to be here.
As Ines said, I'm, my
specialization is in U.S.
and Mexican broadcasting
history.
But, I got interesting from
the [inaudible] perspective
in Latino, Latina media and
radio in particular because it's
such an interesting history.
It's, it's the story
of American radio.
And so, I see that as something
that needs to be included
in the broader picture.
So, I guess I would just
stick to a few points here.
I think the panelists have
made excellent arguments
about the essential everyday
role that radio plays
in the community and
particularly for Latinos.
And that's the fundamental
thing.
But also is the sort
of cultural mission,
the sort of giving
a cultural outlet.
And this reminds me of the
research of [foreign language]
in Columbia, who sort of looks
at, you know, it's the process
of making radio that
constructs the community.
And I think all these cases have
really showed the importance
of that.
The other couple of issues
I would just bring up is,
a couple of interesting
things I think.
One is that while this is on
the one hand a national story.
It's also fundamentally
transnational, right?
All of the, all of the
communities have ties
to other parts of the world,
to the parts of Latin America
and those ties are
part of the story.
And so, we need to think of it,
not just in a national context,
but in a transnational context.
And then, finally, you know,
I think all these cases really
show that these are local
or regional cultures,
right, that are getting,
that are using the
medium of radio.
And that presents difficulties,
I guess, around preservation.
And I think obviously, as
we've discussed the idea
of collaboration is what's going
to make this, bring these local
and regional expressions
and uses of radio into sort
of broader national picture
in transnational picture
of what Spanish language,
multilingual radio is all about.
So, those are just the
points I wanted to make.
And I've really enjoyed
hearing from all the panelists.
[ Applause ]
>> Alejandra Bronfman: So,
we're just going to get started.
We don't have too much time.
But I am told that there is
nothing here until two o'clock,
so if people, if we want
to stay a little bit longer
if you're not too
hunger, we can.
It's really an honor to be here.
It's an honor to share this time
with all of these amazing people
and I'm just, I'm
really inspired
by the presentations
that I just heard.
And I really hope that
we can have a good
conversation afterwards.
It's also an honor to be,
to have sort of been able
to convene this panel with
these incredibly distinguished
archivists, librarians
and researchers.
And what I'm going to do is
just quickly introduce everybody
and without much
further ado get going.
So, we have, we have to
my left, Craig Breaden,
who has been the
audiovisual archivist
at Duke Universities Rubenstein
Rare Book and Manuscript Library
and prior to that was head
of the Media and Oral History
at the Russell Library at
the University of Georgia.
At Duke he processes
and advised on AV
and oral history collections
and since 2015 he's been,
he's managed Voices of
Change, which is as two
and a half year project
funded by NEH to preserve
and describe the
recordings of Radio Haiti,
which is Haiti's
voice of democracy.
And if you don't know
about that project,
he will tell you more about it.
The other two people
who are working
on that project were not
able to be here today.
But it's quite an
amazing collection.
He will be followed by
Christine Heranadez,
who is currently Curator
of Special Collections
at Latin American Library
at Tulane University.
She has a masters and PhD
in anthropology from Tulane.
And has published widely on
the archeology of Mesoamerica,
specializing the prehistory
of [foreign language]
and the [foreign
language] regions
of North and Central Mexico.
And pre Hispanic painted Maya
and Hyland Mexican codices.
She is also the principal
collaborator and responsible
for the electronic resource
the Maya codices database.
And today she's going to be
talking about, I hope maybe,
a collection of Cuban
[foreign language],
which is really interesting.
Jeff Rubin, her colleague, is
the head of Digital Initiatives
and Publishing at Howard Tilton
Memorial Library at Tulane.
He oversees the Tulane
University Digital Library,
Tulane Journal publishing
and Electronic Thesis
and Dissertations
Program as part
of the Tulane University
Digital Repository.
Over the past 18
years, Jeff has worked
on numerous collaborative
digital library projects
with regional, internal
and national partners.
His work at Tulane focuses
on developing new
digital library projects
with collab areas from
across Tulane's campus
and in building Tulane's
open access publishing unit.
So, we have all of these
people who really sort
of know what they're doing
in terms of archiving.
It's an honor.
And finally, one of
our panelists we have,
or actually joining
the session, she may
or may not be chiming in,
we have Ayanna Legros,
who is a first year
history PhD student.
And she has, she is sitting on
a really important radio archive
that we hope to sort of
get going on preserving
as part of this initiative.
Our commenter today
will be Robert Horton,
who is from the National
Museum of American History
and he's assistant director
of collections and archives
and I should say that
I'm Alejandra Bronfman.
I teach Caribbean and Latin
American history at SUNY Albany.
So, Christine.
>> Christine Heranadez:
Thank you.
>> Alejandra Bronfman:
Oh, sorry, Craig.
Sorry.
>> Craig Breaden: Okay.
>> Alejandra Bronfman: Sorry.
>> Craig Breaden: Excuse me.
Woops. Turn it on.
Good morning.
Thank you for being here.
I'm honored and humbled to be
among a group of people here,
who are doing really cool things
and both creators and archivists
and people who are
interested in what we're doing.
I just. It's a great thing.
So, thank you.
I wanted to talk a little bit
about our Radio Haiti
collection at Duke University.
And this is coming
from somebody,
who admittedly I'm an
audiovisual archivist.
I work on a wide
variety of projects.
I don't have the language to
be working on this project.
I don't have the
cultural background
to be working on this project.
The person, who actually
probably should be sitting
in my seat is the person
I manage on the project,
Laura Wagner, who's a
brilliant scholar and writer
and she is our soldier
on this project.
So, I'm going to try to
represent what she's doing
as best as I can as the
manager of the project.
So, the Radio Haiti project.
It's a preservation project.
It's a description project.
It's a repatriation project.
And behind all of that,
it's a human rights project.
And this is what really draws me
to it and keeps my heart in it.
A little bit of background.
Radio Haiti as a political
source in the voice of democracy
in Haiti began in 1971, when
Jean Dominique, the station,
the station's owner
bought the station.
And over the next 30 years he
and his wife, Michele Montas,
created this voice of democracy.
And they kept going, even when
the station was off the air
and they were in exile
in New York City.
They came back twice to Haiti
before Jean Dominique was
assassinated in 2000.
If you're interested in that
story and it's an amazing story,
Jonathan Demme made
a movie about him.
It's a documentary.
It's called the Agronomist.
In 2013 10 years after
the station closed,
because Michele kept the station
open for another three years
after the assassination.
She made the donation
to Duke University
of the 37 hundred
tapes, which equals
out to five thousand
300 digital files,
about 27 hundred hours of audio.
We secured an NEH grant in
2015 and with our obligation
in that grant to provide digital
preservation of the audio
and also basic description
of the tapes.
They came with some
metadata already.
They came with some titles.
But that information
was often incomplete
and sometimes incorrect,
because, you know, that's,
that's the way it goes.
And the couple of years I
spent in a radio station,
sometimes the labels
weren't always as correct
as they probably could be.
So, I think we understood that.
So, part of this collection
and the impetus behind it
was the collecting forces
of our human rights archive,
one of our collecting centers.
Duke, the Rubenstein
Library at Duke,
the Special Collections
Library, wants more and more
to be seen an as
activists library.
And this was really, really a
good example of a collection
that we could sink
our teeth into.
But it also came smack up
against the culture at Duke,
which, you know, is a
traditional research center,
American research library.
It's very traditional.
It wants to be an activist
library, but it also really hues
to the lines of standards,
which is great.
It really, we really use a
lot of what's called NPLP,
which is more product,
less process
in our, in our archiving.
And so, the idea
of spending a lot
of time doing item
level description
on audio was not something that
I think a lot of the people sort
in the leadership were
prepared for going forward.
So, we had some challenges
early on there.
And the, the needs of the
collection really sort
of really brought those
challenges into relief.
This was a collection
that needed multilingual
description for accessibility.
That meant that we had to have
playback of the entire file
that we got back from
a cutting corporation,
which was the company
that digitized the tapes
and did a great job.
And that was actually
the easy part for us.
We needed an understanding
of the context
of the audio's creation.
And this was really important to
really make sensible metadata.
And really most of
all an understanding
of the absolute importance
of Haitian Creole as used
by the station, because it was
revolutionary for its time.
They were the first media outlet
in Haiti to use Haitian Creole,
which was the language
of the people.
And in processing the
collection and working with it,
that is really more and
more has become, in my mind,
the driving force
of the collection
and its continued importance,
its political importance
to the people of
Haiti, its importance
as it was used by the station.
The language that
the station used.
The way they used the language.
They went a long way
towards making parts
of that language concrete.
And so, really understanding the
collection is an understanding
of Haitian Creole.
So, that required
a lot of expertise,
which we got very lucky and
were able to hire Laura Wagner
to do the processing
of the collection.
So, Laura sits and she listens
to audio and she describes it.
And she bring to bear on that
audio a cultural expertise
and cultural context
and history of Haiti
that is really just outstanding.
And there are a lot of
problems regarding especially
authorities, controlled
vocabularies.
LC headings don't really do
for these kinds of collections.
LC headings are not
really tuned to.
Or I should say that
maybe they have all that,
they bring all the
cultural baggage of sort
of mainstream America
with it, right?
So, they don't really think
about how place names might
be constructed in Haiti.
They might not think about how
personal names are constructed
in Haiti.
They might not think about the
way that certain events happened
or the way that certain
events happened might be
through the lens of an
American imperialism.
So, in processing the collection
and wanting to apply, you know,
authorities and controlled
vocabularies
so records could be searched
effectively across collections.
It was a real challenge for us.
And we do a lot of
basically local,
local controlled vocabulary
in describing the collection.
We have database issues with it.
As a trilingual collection.
Well, this actually goes
back to the importance
of the Haitian Creole, but the.
We started out just using a
relational database to try
to wrangle everything together.
But the problem with that was we
had difficulty copying records,
which is really important
when you're creating 51 hundred
records or 53 hundred records.
And the other, the other issue
was that we needed to be able
to get the information out
into a flat spreadsheet,
which we weren't sure we could
do by the end of the project.
So, we went ahead and
ported the database
out to a flat spreadsheet.
Well that spreadsheet
because the metadata has
to be trilingual, has
over 100 fields in it.
And to then ingest that into a
developing digital repository,
has its own set of
complications.
Amidst all of this, we have
to remain very flexible
and very live in our approach to
how we process the collection.
Laura, as brilliant as she
is, can't do it all on her own
in the time that
we have to do it.
So we have to try to find other
people with similar talents,
the language skills, to
be able to help us on it.
Well, you can imagine
that that population
at Duke University
is fairly small.
And we like to use
students when possible,
because it keeps our costs down,
it gives the students
experience.
And in fact, we've
had some great success
with some of our students.
But students graduate.
And so. And Duke has a hard time
hiring outside the university.
We actually just got through
a whole process of trying
to rehire a student
after she graduated,
which set the project back
probably several months.
We've just learned that we
can actually rehire her,
but it took us four
months to do it.
Duke is a large ship,
it's very powerful.
It's well resourced.
But it's very slow to turn.
And so, we want, within
the archive, though,
we want to make good on
that activists promise.
And we want to be able to
say we can do these kinds
of collections because
they're important.
And they're.
I told Michele Montas this
the other week when I saw her,
as I had told her
before, that I really felt
like this was the most
important collection I'll work
on in my lifetime and my career.
And I really truly believe that.
And this is a collection where
I don't even understand the
content when I listen to it.
But the description is going
to make that more accessible
to all of us in the end.
And in our next steps, we hope
that we can go beyond our
repository, which is very useful
if you're a researcher
in the U.S.,
but is less so when
you're in Haiti.
And we want to actually
digitally repatriate it,
hopefully if we get our grant
fulfilled, using YouTube
and the internet archive to go
where Haitians are in Haiti,
because that's where they are.
And to us, that's our,
that's our frontier.
To push an academic library
to actually use that resource
in such a way that it's
effective is really our
next step.
And luckily we have
the rights clearances
to be able to do that.
So. That's a thumbnail of
the work on Radio Haiti.
>> Alejandra Bronfman:
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Christine Heranadez: Thanks.
Thank you very much, Alejandra,
for the invitation to talk
with you, be on the panel.
Thanks also to Josh Shepard
and the Radio Preservation
Task Force
for having their
conference this year.
And giving us the opportunity
to speak with everyone.
So, this morning I'm
going to talk a little bit
about a collection that we
have in the Special Collections
of a Latin American Library
at Tulane University.
It's called the [foreign
language] collection
of Cuban American Radionovelas.
The collections measures
630 linear feet of material,
the bulk of which
are audio tapes.
And in fact, the collection
measures approximately,
in terms of the audio
series its little
under nine thousand
individual tapes.
This is quarter inch polyester
audio tape on seven inch reels.
And that's probably
represents close
to three thousand 600
hours of audio recordings.
The tapes actually, this,
they represent the library
of radio program masters
that were produced
by Americas Productions
Incorporated or API.
This is a company that was
based out of Miami, Florida.
It was founded in 1961
by [foreign language].
Now, prior to, prior to
the 1959 Cuban Revolution,
Cuba was a major producer
or radio programming,
supplying as much
as a 75 percent
of the canned radio programs
that were distributed
to stations throughout
Latin America.
That all, well that was
significantly impacted
by the 59 revolution.
And it also meant the
end to [inaudible] career
as a public relations
man in Havana.
So, after the revolution,
he resettled in Miami,
as did much of the
talent that existed
in Cuba prior to the revolution.
The people who actually helped
to produce these radio programs.
So the actors, the actresses,
directors, script writers,
musicians, technicians.
Many of these folks
resettled in Miami after 1959.
And so, what [inaudible] was
able to do was actually fill
that industry void for
programming production
by founding API and by
making use of the talent
that had pooled there
in Miami after 1959.
Now, the company kind of began
its first couple years producing
very pointed anticommunist
programs
for the U.S. government,
a number of which were
commissioned by Voice of America
for broadcast back to Cuba.
But, what [inaudible]
found was that he,
in order to keep his
company commercially viable,
he was going to have to
kind of shift the focus
of the production of programs.
And so, in 1963 he kind
of put the resources
of the company towards
producing what he called
pure entertainment.
And so, this was going
to be programming
that was more prodemocracy,
pro-capitalist in nature.
Something that one of our
colleagues mentioned yesterday
in one of the Cold
War sessions kind
of propaganda as entertainment.
And so, the idea was that
these would be programs
that he could actually
license to stations
and they would be able
to broadcast them,
because they weren't
so outwardly obviously
anticommunist.
But, these were, the programming
were primarily Radionovelas
or radio dramas,
radio soap operas.
But they also included
mystery and suspense shows.
They did informationals.
They did comedy programs.
They did variety programs.
So, there's a whole
range of programming
that they were producing
in this short stretch
between 1963 and 1970.
And they licensed the programs
to stations throughout
Latin America,
but also more importantly
to the burgeoning
Spanish speaking audiences
in the United States and to
Spanish markets in Europe.
So, they had a wide
distribution.
But I'm not really here this
morning to talk to you all
about the content
of this collection.
What I really wanted to
talk with you is how that,
how I and my colleagues
at Tulane are trying
to put these programs back
on the air, so to speak.
How to convert them and
make them accessible
to the public again.
And the collection came to
Tulane at the end of 2004.
In 2005 the Latin American
Library had a graduate student
who was working to do the rough
inventory of the materials.
And she was able to dub a few
of the tapes onto CD's and do a,
started to a condition
assessment of the tapes.
But that all abruptly came to
an end with Hurricane Katrina.
The playback equipment that
the library had was destroyed
by the flooding.
And so, for the intervening 10
years after that, the tapes,
you know, the work
couldn't continue
on that project until 2015.
Then, the Latin American Library
was again in a position to kind
of return to that project.
Also, though, the parent
library, Howard Tilton,
was also, had digital
capacity by that point.
So, we had, my colleague
Jeff here.
We had the Tulane University
Digital Library was in place.
And so, we actually had more
digital capacity to kind
of come back to this project.
So, was this the right moment?
So, in order to begin in
2015 the first thing we had
to do was establish
the copyright status.
These were tapes that
were produced in kind
of the donut hole of copyright.
Apart from the donor agreement,
I didn't have any documentation
about the multiple
different rights holders
that might have been involved
in the production
of these programs.
And we really needed to be
sure that if we're going
to digitize these
materials and put them online
and make them open
access available
that we were not going
to have any issues.
So, it took eight months
working with Tulane's Office
of the General Council and
with other professionals
in the field, like James Hurtle
and Elizabeth Townsend Gard,
from Tulane's Law School,
to actually get our
copyrights information in order.
We were ready to go ahead.
So, the next step was to
then devise a pilot project.
I don't have a background
in audio preservation
and nor have we any
kind of workflow to deal
with the conversion of
analogs to digital recordings.
So, the purpose of
the pilot project was
to kind of learn that.
And what we did was we, I
made a selection of tapes.
I knew we had some condition
issues to think about.
We had. We knew that
there was some mold.
We knew that there are a number
of poor packed conditions.
And so, the point of the
pilot project really was just
to figure out how much
was it going to cost
to convert these tapes.
How much was it, what
were the workflows?
How much labor were
we going to need
to manage the digital
files, create the metadata?
And then build a
digital collection,
because that was going to be
the outlet for providing access.
To fund this little
project, I looked to a group.
Tulane is a member of the
Center for Research Libraries
and under the Center
for Research Libraries
there is a project
that is called the
Latin American Research
Resources Project.
And the member institutions to
CLR part of their subscription,
their yearly subscription
moneys are pooled and the LARP,
which is the name, the
acronym for this group.
LARP can then fund some small
digitization initiatives
for the member institutions.
So, we were fortunate
to get a little
over eight thousand dollars
to do that pilot project.
We worked with George
Blood Audio
to help us with conversion.
And we were able to
actually do 194 tapes.
So by the end of 2016 we
had our 194 tapes digitized.
Actually, they had some
conservation done on them.
They were digitized.
We created the metadata and
we were able to get them up,
get a digital collection
up in the Tulane
University Digital Library.
We also at that time were able
to complete a condition
assessment
of a four percent sample of the
total number of audio tapes.
So, we had a good idea of what
our conditioning issues were.
And now know approximately
how much, in terms of funding
and labor resources it's going
to take convert the
entire library
of eight thousand
900 and some tapes.
So, let me show you.
It kind of went ahead of my.
There's the homepage for
the digital collection.
We have eight titles up there.
Three of them in their entirety.
So, we have all the
episodes for the stories,
have a good sampling
of some of the content.
And we'll show you in a minute
what the metadata looks like.
Metadata is done both
in English and Spanish.
And so, now in 2017, what
we're able to continue
to do is now we have that
experience and the knowledge to,
you know, to pursue some larger
grant funding opportunities
to keep going with
the conversion.
And at the moment, we're
currently proceeding
with doing kind of mold
remediation and cleaning
of the tapes, kind of to be
ready for when we might be able
to continue with conversion.
Approximately one third
of the total collection
of tapes has some
condition issues.
So, we're just going to
continue with that work.
So, with that, I'm going to hand
the podium over to my colleague,
Jeff Rubin, who's going to tell
you a little bit more about some
of the cool stuff that's
happening on that end.
Okay, Jeff.
>> Jeff Rubin: Should
I come up there?
>> Christine Heranadez:
If you'd like
[ Applause ]
>> Jeff Rubin: Well,
thank you everyone.
The. I'm not sure
where I'm going here.
So the collection, the
process actually we, what I.
The part of the library
that I oversee is the sort
of production and
access component
of our collections and how we.
We have a platform that provides
basically open access to all
of our collection materials
that were digitized.
This. once we got into
the position to be able
to distribute these materials
to make them available to anyone
who wants to read them or
to listen to them, we had,
we had sort of part of
the process figured out.
The. The difficulty, though, is
that our proposal to go forward
to have these tapes
digitized was,
the cost of that portion
didn't cover the cost
of this initial cleaning and
conservation of the tapes.
So, that is what we're
having to do in house
and through Chris's students.
Here's a slide of our student
worker, Rebecca, vacuuming
and cleaning the
reels in the boxes
of each of these audio tapes.
What we ended up coming across
was that each tape was going
to require somebody manually
sort of cleaning the tape
for the entire, you know,
one to one real time running
of each tape, which is a
horrible job for somebody
and especially for a student.
So, what. We had
this serendipitous.
This meeting that
Chris had with one
of our new faculty at Tulane.
His name is Philippe Cruz
and he is a Brazilian
and he is a Brazilian historian,
a historian of Brazil.
And Chris had a meeting
with him and it turns
out he was very interested
in Tulane's Maker Space.
Tulane has a new
3D printing space
and with lots of equipment.
Let me show you this.
And we thought.
We were trying to figure out
how can we take the manual labor
out of cleaning these, these
tapes and just have them run
and Philippe and Chris and
I were talking and we came
up with this idea to 3D print an
extra reel, a set of, kind of,
these, I don't, these reels
that tape goes over and under
and cleans the tape without
having a student to having
to sort of hold the
clothe and do it manually.
So we.
Philippe, he knew how
to do this already.
And he sort of just jumped in.
and wanted to, to design
and build and print
out this little gadget.
And you have, that's
not even a gadget.
It's a widget really.
It's just a piece of solid
plastic that printed out.
And this Maker Space is open to
people on the campus for free.
You can just go in and get sort
of quickly certified
to run the equipment.
Send files in.
what we came up with
was, was this.
And so, there's a, a video
here that I will play.
If I can find that
presentation load.
It has stopped working.
Let's see if I can.
Let's get this back up.
Did we have them up here?
We didn't.
Let me open this real quick.
So, the, the video
it just shows.
This is it, huh.
There we go.
And if we can slide show.
And play.
[ Inaudible ]
There we go.
Let's see if.
So, we sort of had this
printed and kind of attached it
to the side of the
machine and it runs over.
There's no tension really
being applied to the tape.
But it sort of gently goes
over these cleaning materials
and takes off sort of the layer
of, of dust and sort of some
of the loose iron
oxide bits on the tape.
Let's get back to.
[ Inaudible ]
Yeah, we'll do this.
So, the other part of it.
So, now we have this other
collaborator with us, this,
Philippe, who it turned out
to be just perfectly timed
to fall right into our laps.
We couldn't have
planned it any better.
That is going on now.
And the. So, Craig is
doing three languages.
We're only doing two.
But the work of doing Spanish
and English metadata
is very time consuming.
We are having all
of the metadata
in both of these languages.
But we're also needing people
to, to look at the content,
to listen to the content and
describe that information.
So, when we should find
out in late December whether
we get funding to do the,
that initial third of all
of these tapes for, to do.
And this is.
So, this is.
We've done another
radio project at Tulane.
We did a project for the WTUL,
which is the Tulane University
independent radio station.
We have an archive
of those materials.
The only other audio project I
have ever done was another radio
broadcast, but this was a
broadcast of jazz radio programs
from the New Orleans Jazz Club.
And I did this when I was
Louisiana State Museum,
where I spent the first
20 years of my career.
So, the main difference between.
That was about eight
years ago that project.
And this project.
The difference between then
and now is the equipment is
no longer available to buy.
Reel to reel decks are
few and far between.
There are very few
makers of, manufacturers
of reel to reel decks.
The ones that are, are doing
very high end, you know,
10 thousand dollar
and up machines.
So, we had to go
and find a deck on,
through a third party
company that goes
and this is their passion.
They go and they rebuilt
reel to reel decks.
And currently we have one.
And what we need
to do is we need
to find two, three, four more.
So that we can have this
sort of assembly line
of tapes going at the same time.
And so, yeah my expertise in
this is not in the content
at all, but is really in
facilitation of the sort
of analog to digital and then
the publishing of this material.
And so, once we are done, all of
this material will open access
and available to everybody.
And then, the key that
we're trying to find
out is how is this
material going to be used.
How do we, how do we add
knowledge, how do we find people
to use this material,
add knowledge to it
so it just doesn't become
something sitting on a shelf
that someone can listen
to, but how is it going
to be used in classroom?
How can it be used for the study
of various cultural aspects
of history or economic
aspects of it?
And how do we get that into
the classroom, whether it's K
through 12 or, you
know, higher education.
So, that's what we're looking
at and trying to sort of figure
out is hopefully we can get
these materials used, you know,
and become a resource
for others.
So. That's what we have.
>> Alejandra Bronfman: Great.
Thank you.
>> Jeff Rubin: Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Alejandra Bronfman:
Okay, so I'm going
to hand it over to Robert now.
And then, Ayanna, if you want
to say a few things after Robert
that would be great or not.
Okay.
>> Antonio Pereira:
Great, thank you very much.
Let me echo, I'll start
by echoing what a lot
of people have said is
first thanks to Josh Shepard
for putting together this
extraordinary conference.
And echo as well what I
think people have said
about what makes it
extraordinary is that it crosses
so many different boundaries.
I mean, we've brought
together scholars.
We've brought together people
in the IT world, archives world,
communities, creators of
content, users of content.
And that's unique in many ways.
I think most of us,
you generally just meet amongst
ourselves and talk to ourselves.
Well, I certainly
talk to myself.
But I meant talk
amongst ourselves.
But I think what we're
also experiencing
and certainly something that
we need to address is the fact
that we all speak
different languages as well.
And the point I would
make after having listened
to the conversations
over the past few days
and certainly this
session as well is that.
And I'll borrow these
terms with all apologies
from Marx's capital is that the
researchers in the communities,
a lot of the users of the
content speak about use value.
When they look at a
collection, they'll talk
about this would be
great for a class.
It's essential for my research.
This tells a story
of a community.
And I think archivists and
especially those archivists
like I, who are managers
of archives,
talk in terms of exchange value.
This is, collection is one
opportunity among many.
And I look at it and evaluate
it in terms of resources
and capacity and, and priorities
that how do I, how am I going
to deal with the
challenges of mold.
How am I going to deal with
process of description?
How am I going to, when
I have a limited budget.
And the Smithsonian has a
relatively large budget,
but it's going.
I mean all of us are
increasingly looking to deal
with the fact that our,
in the cultural heritage
world our budgets are moving
from a program based to a
project based foundation,
meaning that for
example the Smithsonian,
the Federal Government
pays essentially
for buildings and staff.
Everything else has
to be raised.
Funds have to be raised.
And I think that's true as you
listen to everyone talking today
about these projects
are all grand funded.
When those grants go
away, what happens?
Increasingly, we're
putting things together
in this ad hock one
project to another hoping
that it'll all come magically
together at some point
and things will be preserved
and we'll make it all work.
That's a tremendous challenge.
And I think everyone's kind
of underscored the fact
that the answer to that is
going to be collaboration.
But, I would add a couple
of different things.
One -- I think of,
how should I put this?
I think collecting is
always the easy part.
And that the collecting really
needs to be addressed in terms
of a continuum of care
that there is collecting.
And that's just the start.
There's processing.
There's description.
There's providing access.
There's preservation.
A
And in a digital world,
preservation is an ongoing,
it's really an interminable
project, right?
The technology is
going to change.
So, I would urge everyone
who is creating content
or collecting content to
think of a collaboration
within archives, not
in terms of a handoff.
Okay, now it's your problem.
But how do you start right
from the beginning to think
about that entire
continuum of care.
And realize that in many ways
that the point of acquisition
by an archivists is the point
where you get the best chance
of raising the money to
deal with that collection.
That very often, you know,
if you give something
to an archives, it is going
to go into the back of a room.
It is going to be
stowed on a shelf.
It is not going to be
addressed because a whole bunch
of other collections are
coming in at the same time.
so, I think, you know,
understanding how we might look
to sharing responsibilities at
an earlier and earlier point
in a continuum or a lifecycle
of a collection is
really important.
The other thing I would
say from the perspective
of the archives is that we
have to start thinking in terms
of beyond the boundaries of
the four walls of our archives.
I mean, we have traditionally
thought that everything happens
and this is certainly
true of the Museum
of American History
and the Smithsonian.
Everything happens
in that building.
We collect it.
We take care of it.
We describe it.
We interpret it.
We assign meaning to these
content, to this content.
And increasingly that's
not atenable proposition
for all sorts of reasons.
Not simply because of the budget
problems, which, you know,
plague me, but also, and
the idea that, you know,
we're not just sharing
information now,
we're really sharing authority.
It is not the role of the
Smithsonian or the Museum
of American History to
interpret a collection.
We want to be able to make
that collection available
for other people to
interpret and other people
to tell us what it means.
So, looking for collaborations
that involve, I think,
on one hand on the financial
scale, scale, or dealing with,
or financial [inaudible]
dealing with scale.
You know, not treating
problems or collections
as a boutique effort that
we're going to address once
and somehow raise the money.
But looking for ways to share
infrastructure and enable to us
to drive down the costs.
Because everything you guys
have said was kind of staggering
in terms of the manual
labor involved.
I mean, tape by tape by tape.
That's a huge cost.
So, how do you address that?
It's not going to
happen in one institution
and then another institution
and another institution all
duplicating efforts competing
for the same funds, building
the same kind of infrastructure.
So, those collaborations
are essential.
The other thing I
would say in terms of.
And that has to be driven by
the archivists and the museums
and the culture of
heritage institutions.
The other thing I
would say is, you know,
essentially that we can,
you know, take advantage
of technology in the sense
that a lot of the activities
that have traditionally
been seen as archivally,
archival those functions
can be shared.
And should be shared,
especially in terms
of description and
interpretation.
There was a wonderful session on
metadata yesterday, which talked
about the whole number of
different ways you can collect
and aggregate metadata.
And a lot of them were not
being done by the archivists.
There's Google Forums,
there's aggregation.
There's a wonderful project out
of Washington State run by one
of my heros, Kim Withee
Macutu [assumed spelling],
which is essentially a
collections management system
that allows indigenous
peoples to assign values
and descriptions, definitions to
content that other people hold.
And the variant to that is what
something also Kim has worked
on is traditional
knowledge labels,
where you can essentially if
you open up your catalogue
as in archives, someone else can
assign content to it as well,
interpretations and metadata.
And so, there's a whole
variety of technology,
technological options that we
should be actively exploring.
But they're going to start on
the premises that we're going
to give up some of our custodial
role, we're going to give
up some of our traditional
roles and responsibilities
and we've just got to
share, not just information,
which is what we've always
tried to do, but share authority
and more importantly
share control.
So, I think there are a variety
of things we could tease out.
But I mean, the larger
point I was going
to make is it's not going
to happen in one collection
at a time, because we simply
cannot manage the costs
when we look at things
like that.
>> Alejandra Bronfman:
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
Okay. So, at this point, I don't
know if Ayanna you want to,
if Ayanna you want
to say anything?
Ayanna is trying to find
a home for a collection
of how many tapes is it?
900?
>> Ayanna Legros: 900.
>> Alejandra Bronfman: 900 tapes
of a radio program
[foreign language],
which ran from 1969 to 2000?
>> Ayanna Legros: Two.
>> Alejandra Bronfman: Two.
And I don't know, do you want
to say anything about it?
See if you can?
>> Ayanna Legros: Yeah,
can people like hear me?
>> Alejandra Bronfman:
Can you hear her?
Yeah?
>> Ayanna Legros: Oh wow.
Okay. Great.
Well good afternoon everyone.
So, my Ayanna Legros.
I am a first year PhD student in
the History Department at Duke.
So, there are definitely
some overlaps
between Craig and I's narrative.
But I'll just open
up with something
out of Columbia Universities
Daily Spectator Newspaper
from April 4th, 1986.
For the past 16 years members
of New York City Haitian
community have aired [foreign
language], the Haitian Hour,
from Columbia student
operated radio station WKCR.
Broadcast in Creole,
the show purpose
to keep the Haitian community
in the tri state area informed
about activities in Haiti and
other U.S. Haitian communities.
But the shows controversial
politics have brought a host
death and bomb threats, as
well as threatened lawsuits
against the shows
inflammatory program director
and broadcaster [foreign
language]
volatile leftist content has
raised questions regarding the
shows compliance with WKCR
and Federal Communications
Commission, FCC,
guidelines concerning
the broadcasting
of political editorials
and monitoring procedures.
Quote -- in trying to
serve both the New York
and Columbia communities,
we entered into an incredible
quagmire of legal, social,
linguistic, administrative
and punitive problems,
said Jonathon, WKCR's
station manager in 1985.
So, [foreign language] ran
between 1969 through 2002
out of WKCR, which is New York,
which is Columbia
University's radio station.
The show was founded by a group
of Haitian exiles slash students
and was run in Haitian
Creole and at times
in French and English.
As the paragraph shares, the
show sought to connect members
of the Haitian diaspora in
New York across the boroughs
and disseminated news
Haitian culture and music.
My interest in this project
was actually an accident,
in that I was speaking with
one of my dad's friends
and he mentioned that
these tapes were around.
And obviously, I
knew about the show.
As a little girl, I
often attended protests
with my parents in New
York City regarding issues
from [foreign language] death
to [inaudible] being
overthrown and such matters.
But honestly, I had
forgotten about the show,
similar to my family members,
because of the reality
that Haiti was not
going to be a space
that we could return
to as a family.
And so, in just a
random conversation
with my dad's friend, he
mentioned that these tapes were
around and they're in a
tool shed in Long Island.
And so, this summer, like
most people who are interested
in archival projects, I
ended up in someone's garage
and tool shed kind of
digging through what existed.
Very similar to Craig, this
interest is really driven
by a desire to tell a
narrative about democracy,
both in the United
States and Haiti.
It's about Creole.
It's about the diaspora.
It's about living in exile.
But, one thing that I
find incredibly unique
about [foreign language] is
really kind of the desire
to decolonize a university
space.
What does it mean to be
a political radio show
within a university
setting, particularly
like Columbia University?
And so, in those conversations
and in my desires of wanting
to donate this collection,
I've come across a
series of questions.
Does Columbia University own
these rights for this show?
Does, do the owners or creators
of the show own the rights?
Does WKCR, the radio station
that operates independently
out of Columbia University
own the rights?
And so, there are so
many questions in, in,
in seeking to find a home
for an archival collection.
And I do want to share
that if there's anything
that this process
has taught me it's
that there's a major disconnect
between scholars and archivists,
in terms of the type of labor
it takes to compose an archive.
And so, I've become very
appreciative of, you know,
just the mere action of walking
into a library and speaking
with an archivist
around what is around.
And so, if anyone has
any suggestions or ways
that they can support in
this archive finding a home,
Alejandra can share my
contact information.
And I want to thank you all for
allowing me to join in with you
on this Saturday afternoon.
>> Alejandra Bronfman:
Thank you.
[Applause].
So I think we all
share a lot in,
of sort of similar
concerns and interests.
So, I'm just going to
throw it open now for all
of the panelists, all of
the questions for anybody
who spoke even earlier.
Questions, comments.
Yeah?
>> What is the name
of the collection
that is being offered?
>> Alejandra Bronfman: This one?
>> Yeah.
>> Alejandra Bronfman:
It's [foreign language].
>> Ayanna Legros: It
means the Haitian Hour.
>> Alejandra Bronfman:
The Haitian Hour.
Yeah.
Questions, comments.
Yeah?
[ Inaudible ]
>> Either over the
air or online, right?
That's a way.
Sorry. That's, you know,
one way to remind people
of the importance
of these materials.
So, I think that's
the other piece
of the collaboration
circle is, you know,
are our various options.
And, you know, this
may go back to some
of the conversation this
morning about the importance
of college radio, the importance
of low power FM, right?
That there are these radio
outlets that we might be able
to utilize as a way to kind of
complete that circle, right?
and, you know, bring these
materials back to people,
which also then is a
reminder of their importance
if we can deal with, you
know, as was brought up,
the rights questions and some of
those things that may come up,
which are of course
going to be part of that.
But, so, I think there are
a lot of really, you know,
great opportunities to
do those kind of things.
And I'll just say really
quickly, I mean, you know,
my work is mostly in Argentina
and [foreign language] is
actually doing this great thing
where they're bringing back old
radionovelas, not super old,
but from the 60's and 70's,
putting them back on the air
and putting them up on their
website, so, with information,
with some documentation.
So, I mean, they're bringing
it back and, you know,
using it as content, but
also as a way of kind
of reminding people of,
you know, bringing some
of those historical
material back
into people's consciousness.
So, I think there's a
lot of interesting things
that can be done there
in the right situation.
Thanks.
>> Alejandra Bronfman: Yeah?
[ Inaudible ]
>> Oh, thank you.
In terms of preservation,
I was wondering
if there's other
strategies besides, you know,
room temperature rooms and
so forth in terms of tapes.
Because I'm just thinking about
all the various different,
particularly in the area
that I'm working in,
in terms of Spanish language,
bilingual, indigenous programing
that sometimes is not even
located in a radio station,
but it's just a program
that happens once a
week, or once a month.
And so, trying to think
about how do we preserve
those programs
that don't even have a
bigger infrastructure.
If there's any strategies
that you can offer
that folks might be able to
take back to be able to utilize,
either that can still be sort
of DIY or that, you know,
it doesn't have to be so labor
or capital, you know, intensive.
>> Antonio Pereira: Right.
Well, two things.
I mean for older content
that, the content that's
on analog media, I don't
think there's an easy answer.
I mean you are looking at
some kind of a migration
or digitization process
that is going
to cost some amount of money.
There's a, I think from
this point forward approach
to contents being created
now that could, you know,
reasonably, and this
could be, you know,
for an interesting project is to
start setting up some sort of,
I hate to use the
term best practices
because that usually means
really expensive practices.
But, you know, more appropriate
practices that will allow people
to sort of understand if
we want to preserve this,
here are some things we
should do at this point,
the point of creation
that'll make all
of those necessary
migrations, etcetera,
simpler and less expensive.
And I think that would
be relatively easy to do,
especially in audio, which
we're, you know, we really kind
of understand the digital world.
Video is a little
more difficult.
It's still kind of
wild, Wild West.
But in the audio world, I
think we could setup a variety
of suggestions and guidelines
that would lower the cost
ultimately of preservation.
It would make the handoffs much
simpler and easier to achieve.
But, as far as analog goes,
that's, that's still costly.
I don't know any other
ways around that.
>> Hi, it's such an
interesting panel.
Thank you.
If there is anything
that I've kind
of learned the last two day is
the significance of undergrads,
grad students and interns.
In radio preservation,
there's this need for them
to do this manual labor that was
also mentioned on this panel,
which yes provides a
learning experience
and they get compensated with
credits and learning experience,
but it's also, we look to them
for cheap labor in
some way, right?
But I think this
is the one panel,
particularly your comments
that kind of made me feel
that we could shift some
of the collaboration
dynamics with that.
And by saying that once
you share collaboration,
you share authority.
So, this idea of including
everybody, not just people
who tap into the archives,
but kind of acknowledging
who found them, who's
cataloging them,
who's cleaning them, right?
I think it'd be really
interesting to kind
of rethink preservation
by including everybody
that is a part of every
single step, right?
Not just the person who
authors the ultimate paper
or something like that.
So, it was very thought
provoking panel.
Thank you.
>> Alejandra Bronfman: Yeah,
I just want to jump onto that
because I've been thinking
as everybody has been speaking
including the first panel
and then ours and then
your comments as well,
is that it strikes me
that one of the things
about these two panels is
about is decolonization, right?
And decolonizing radio studies,
decolonizing radio
and all of that.
And as much as I liked the first
two talks by Michele Hilmes
and Susan Douglas, that's not
one of the sort of priorities
that they set for radio
studies and I think
that we really need make a push
for that, in terms of just look
at where we are in the program.
Look at how they've put
us opposite, you know,
African American studies,
which we would actually benefit
from all going to that panel.
So, I think that there's a real
need to kind of keep pushing.
So, yeah. And especially in
terms of what Robert said
about de-authorizing the archive
and things like that as well.
[Inaudible].
Yeah. [Inaudible].
Yeah, that's right.
Yeah.
>> [inaudible] broader
priorities that are happening
within the task force.
And about what exactly it
is that we're doing here.
So, I mean, I think that those
are bigger questions of us,
but also power that are
not really being addressed,
but that we are sort
of underlying a lot
of what's being discussed.
>> Alejandra Bronfman:
Yeah, I agree.
>> Craig Breaden: Can I chime
in on that a little bit?
>> Alejandra Bronfman: Yeah.
>> Craig Breaden: We.
I think whether or not
we get a second grant
for our Radio Haiti stuff,
we're going to explore
the YouTube possibility
for putting the collection
on there,
which obviously there are a lot
of technical problems with that.
But we've talked to
YouTube a little bit
and they're interested
in supporting that.
And the idea, of course,
is to be rebroadcasting
that material in Haiti.
That's essentially
what we'd be doing.
But, to your question about DIY?
I love DIY and as an
archivist in a big institution,
it's not real, it's not
a real popular stance
because we have all sorts
of standards that we have
to really [inaudible] to.
But there are a lot of tools
out there now that you can use
with some risks, but I got to
tell you that there are risks
in an institutional
archive like my own as well
that you need to
take into account.
But, between YouTube,
Google Drive, Amazon Cloud,
the things that can be done
DIY to keep your stuff safe
if you do it with a design,
is something that is,
is actually possible today.
The tools are there.
And I occasionally teach
an oral history workshop
and I have people come in
from the community, you know,
or small historical societies
and they ask me this
question, like what can we do.
And I say well there are
a lot of tools out there.
And they know what
the tools are,
but the important part
is to have a plan.
And to. And the standards
for metadata
that we use are really
readily available
and they can be used
for any collection.
It doesn't have to
just be in a library.
So, I really encourage, I really
encourage DIY if it's done
in a way that has
a design behind it,
because if that material
ends up going
to an institutional archive,
like Duke or someplace
like that, that gives us a real
leg up in the process of trying
to move those materials
into the archive.
Even if every, you
know, T isn't' crossed
and I isn't dotted,
it really helps us.
And I think actually I had this
conversation with Ayanna as well
about some basic tools
that can be used.
So.
>> I don't know.
This is. If I am
going to express it
in quite the way
that will make sense.
But I. one of the points
that was made earlier
in the morning session
too was the talk
about how important global radio
is because it's so valuable
in third world countries.
But the truth is that within the
United States it's very valuable
to communities of color.
And that's one thing too that,
you know, I've heard in going
to the different sessions.
And the value of making
sure that that's archived is
because they were
talking about worried
about the future of radio.
But the truth is that radio is,
is effective tool right now,
you know, in communities
of color.
And that's not going
to change too soon.
Because when you look at
areas like Eastern Washington,
there is also a digital divide.
So, it's not like everybody has
access, you know, to internet
or podcasts or internet radio.
It's radio that's
the effective tool.
And its radio that goes
out into, you know,
the agriculture fields and as
Ines mentioned that the one
that you hear in
restaurants and so forth.
So, it's still a very
viable and important means
of mass communication
for communities
of color in this country.
>> I actually, you know, this
is such an interesting idea.
The idea of putting
archives back on the air.
I'm letting it kind of
stew and sit with me
because there's some, you
know, Mexican radio programs
from the 1920's, 30's that I do
not want to, I don't want to get
that back on the air now, right?
and there is such a struggle
to have fresh contemporary
programming,
something that was
not used previously
on Spanish language
broadcast radio
at least in the United States.
That, I'm just, I'm having
it stew a little bit.
In the [foreign language] I
actually heard a presentation
from [foreign language] who
has done a preliminary analysis
of some of those shows
and she does amazing,
amazing archival work.
Her analysis was amazing.
But she gave a wonderful
political kind
of racial analysis of that,
Cuban [foreign language].
And I'm not sure if you replayed
that today how listeners
would react.
Because the political
context is so different
and depending on the listeners.
So, I'm kind of thinking of what
little I know of that archive
and how excited Spanish
language radio listeners are.
You know, I'm thinking
of like even
with [foreign language] the 70's
when Latin File was on the air,
how that was politically
significant
because it was something
fresh and contemporary.
And it wasn't something
that somebody pulled out.
Because I think people
automatically think oh it's
because of budget cuts or
there's nothing else to fill
in the content of
it kind of thing.
So, I love the idea of it,
but I'm letting it stew
within this other, with all
these other kind of factors
that I'm kind of thinking about.
FYI.
>> Thank you.
So, I'm Laura [foreign
language] and I work at NPR
and I manage the archives
and our digitalization labs.
And two things I want to say.
One about interns and doing
in house digitization.
I'm going to the point
of equipment being
very difficult to find.
The way we do it, I
have 20 [inaudible] now.
I ask [inaudible] and email,
I email groups of engineers,
broadcast engineers,
public radio people
to ask do you have any
[inaudible] in your garage,
in your, you know,
basement, whatever.
Can you give it to me
in any shape or form?
And I got 15.
And we had about two or three
and then now I got more.
So, in total if have 20.
We are [inaudible] each one and
we are making new ones out of,
I mean we refurbished them.
So, that gave us a very
good beginning for our lab.
So far in two years we
have digitalized 60,
no 45 thousand hours from
CD and reels, mostly reels.
About interns, we use, I have
two staff, audio engineers,
two audio engineers or your
specialist and we work with up
to three interns per term.
So, if I find the
right candidate,
I will have nine
interns in one year.
But, yes they are not cheap
labor, they are students.
But they are getting lots of
knowledge and the way I see it,
I am preparing audiovisual
people for the field.
Because in the future, all of
you will have to be digitizing.
All of us in this
conference here.
Eventually those
archives will have to be.
And you know what I feel
we will lots of expert,
because what they are doing
in our labs is high scale.
We do sometimes 48
tapes in one day.
So, that is 48 hours.
And the other good things, most
of these students are women.
So, we are getting women
in the field as well.
>> Alejandra Bronfman:
Anything else.
I guess it's almost
time to be done.
I just had an idea
as we were talking
that maybe we'd do this
a little bit informally,
but maybe we should have
a list server that anybody
in this room can
join and we can sort
of keep this conversation going.
So it doesn't just
happen once a year.
So, maybe if you just want to
come up and write your name down
and see if I can sort of create
a list or whatever it is that.
I think that that
would be really useful.
But I just want to thank both
panels, everybody on the panels
for coming and sharing
and talking today.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.